[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast I'm your host Greg Knuckles and
today I'm joined by a guest co-host Dr
Milo wolf Milo how's it going hey man
it's going pretty well it's uh evening
time here in the UK but it's about
midday for you so you know just had a
long day of work but about to smash it
on the Strong by science podcast hell
yeah well hopefully hopefully this will
be a good way to uh to start winding
down and enjoying your evening um would
would would you say you're more
introverted or extroverted cuz either
this will be like a fun way to to start
your evening but also just really really
mess with with the winding down process
or it will absolutely destroy you such
that you're exhausted but but winding
down and and finishing your day will be
smooth as butter it's an interesting
question I actually did take a
personality test a few years ago the big
five for anyone who's in the know um
boringly enough I just scored about 50th
per off so as far as extra version goes
I am disappointingly average uh so it's
going to be ni neither a particularly
Pleasant nor unpleasant experience I
suppose well that's a that affective
veilance that's another that's another
thing entirely like I'm talking whether
you're going to derive energy from this
or not hope hopefully it's going to be
fun regardless but yeah so I uh I figure
a lot of people listening to this
already know who you are but uh for
people who don't we will do a a formal
introduction once we get into the meat
of this episode um but for now what
what's on your mind uh do you have any
media recommendations shoutouts or other
happy thoughts to get the Good Vibes
rolling here I mean first things first
got to give a shout out to uh Dr pack
who I think will have been on the
podcast very very recently as of the
time of this release or look forward to
his episode in case it hasn't been out
yet um as far as media recommendations
I've actually been watching a series
called genius on Disney plus and it's
the series about various quotequote
important historical figures so for
example the first season is
exclusively shot in a kind of fictional
way but true to life events and it's
about different people so season one for
example was about the life of Albert
Einstein sort of from childhood to his
death and then there's a season on
Picasso and some other people as well
and so far it's actually been very good
and in case you didn't know uh Einstein
eventually ended up marrying his cousin
so yes he did that is a darker fact that
I think not many people are I certainly
wasn't and it's uh it's been interesting
topic to navigate oh man hopefully
hopefully I'm not uh just slandering him
in his grave right now but I think not
only did he marry his cousin he was
also like from the jump like
intentionally kind of a you know I was
going to say shitty partner uh I don't
know what the details of their
relationships were maybe it was
something they both agreed to whatever
um but but definitely like an atypical
type of deal beyond the marrying your
cousin bit I believe he sent her a
letter like right before or right after
they got married where he said and I
think this is very close to a direct
quote uh expect neither intimacy nor
Fidelity which yes that's that's crazy
because like okay okay th
this I don't you know I I don't want to
make it sound like I'm at all interested
in any of my cousins in that way but I
feel like I feel like in a society where
there's like tabos against that right I
feel like you're only I feel like one of
the things that might make someone be
interested in their cousin like that is
is if they are just like damn like you
are very hot like I'm very into you
like or like I don't know or or if it's
just like a sort of familiarity thing
where like you're trying to stay like
close to to family folks but like maybe
you're like asexual is so it's like a
little less weird like I I don't like
there there are there are some
permutations of that that like I I
wouldn't be able to like empathize with
but if someone explain it to me i' be
like I kind of see what's going on
whatever but like expect neither
intimacy nor more Fidelity it's just
like what what why why are you walking
down this road man what are you doing
here what are you doing here Fu for sure
man I think the way I see it and keep in
mind all of my information virtually is
coming from this documentary I have not
fact any of this right but essentially
what happened is he married a physicist
right uh named reeva who in her own
right seemed very brilliant but um
eventually realized oh I'm developing
feelings for my cousin and therefore
sent out a letter of requirements to his
wife meva because she wasn't willing to
divorce him so it's essentially almost
like extortion where it was like okay
you're going to leave the room whenever
I asked you to oh that that was that was
to his first wife yes and then um the
the reason at least in the movie is
portrayed as as to why he actually ends
up marrying his cousin is because uh his
original wife meva the physicist uh
seemingly didn't do well was dealing
with poor mental health and was also uh
according to his own mother struggling
to fulfill the roles of a good housewife
and therefore he saw his cousin doing
all of those things perfectly and was
like hm I may want to get a piece of
this I see I
see I feel like scientists back in the
day were like a
lot a lot more uninhibited or or maybe
it's just like more has come out about
them like with uh with the benefits of
historical hindsight but like
Einstein
um Steven Hawking uh being being a
quadriplegic and still finding out a way
like figuring out a way to cheat on his
wife like
yeah that I I feel like that was I feel
like that was a weird profession who
knows who knows I mean who knows what
modern physicists are up to maybe 50
years from now we're going to look back
and be like damn the the guys today are
also uh
absolute
uh people who approach relationships in
an atypical manner who knows uh but cool
that's that's a good recommendation I
very well might check that out um mine
is a a dental hygiene related
recommendation so um typical toothpaste
the active ingredient is fluoride and
the way that uh fluoride Works
essentially is like the main the main
mineral composing your teeth is calcium
phosphate and uh fluoride can kind of so
if if you get like calcium stripping
from any of your teeth and you kind of
have like
exposed
um phosphate with that kind of is still
carrying an an ionic charge um fluoride
can kind of like hook on to those
exposed exposed phosphates and kind of
like plug in where the calcium got
Stripped Away um and I think I think
fluoride and phosphate actually form a
stronger Bond than calcium and phosphate
do so like not only does it replace the
calcium you lose but like it it's it's
like a pretty durable patch that that
one could put on a tooth uh chemically
speaking but the problem there uh is
that if you start getting relatively
significant tooth decay such that like
you've lost both calcium and phosphate
from like a region of a tooth just using
fluoride can help um can help reduce the
rate at which you continue to
demineralize the tooth but but like it's
it's not it's not bringing back what you
fully
lost uh so there is another chemical uh
that one can find in toothpaste some
places called hydroxy appeti which is
just the the kind of like mineral name
for calcium phosphate like it it is the
stuff in your teeth um and it can
actually kind of help like plug those
plug those holes where you do actually
have like uh like actual tooth decay
like it's it's not going to fully
reverse a full-on cavity that's formed
but like little kind of like micro
fissures in your teeth where you have
demineralization uh hydroxy appeti in
toothpaste um can kind of like plug in
and and fill those gaps and so it
was difficult to find pretty much
anywhere outside of Asia until quite
recently um it was developed by NASA
because they thought for some reason
like I'm I'm not totally sure on the
history here but I think they thought
for some reason um fluoride might not
work like like fluoridated toothpaste
may not work the same way in space or
that they might just have to have like
even more heavy duty toothpaste due to
kind of the effects of unloading from
Gravity like they they knew that would
be bad for bones maybe it would be bad
for teeth as well uh so anyway NASA did
research on just using hydroxy Appetit
um for like tooth toothpaste
applications for astronauts but at some
point they lost interest in it uh I I
don't know exactly why it could be that
microgravity doesn't negatively affect
tooth Health the same way it does bone
health could be that like floridated
toothpaste still work just fine uh I'm
not I'm not totally sure but basically
like it it was their patent but they
were just like ah we don't really care
about this anymore like we're just going
to sell off this patent and it was
bought by I believe a Japanese company
like in the 60s or 70s and then there
there's a bit of a saga of
like law fair sort of to keep hydroxy
appetite toothpaste out of a lot of
other countries because like if you if
you go to the store and see a lot of
brands of toothpaste I don't know the
extent to which this is the case in
Europe but like it's the case in the US
you can see a lot of brands of
toothpaste but they're mostly owned by
just like two or three companies um and
they they kind of have that market
cornered and uh you know they they have
like economies of scale efficient
manufacturing practices they just buy up
most of the Shelf space and stores where
one might put toothpaste and so it it
would be difficult for like a new
toothpaste company to get like a really
strong foothold in the market and
challenged them with just like typical
fluoridated toothpaste but if someone
came in and they said hey we have we
have this other ingredient that like
fights cavities via a totally different
way like that that may be a good way for
someone else to get a foothold in the
market so they uh you know they they had
their lawyers talk to Regulators for a
long time and um you know in like inure
that it would be very difficult for for
hydroxy appetite toothpastes to come
into the US and compete with them um so
anyway I'm not sure I'm not totally sure
what's happened recently um maybe there
were just like regulatory changes maybe
some like cord order expired like I have
no idea but I started getting ads for
hydroxy appeti toothpaste I and like so
I I knew uh like some of that history
and I'll tell you where I heard it uh
giving credit where it's due one of our
uh one of our macro Factor developers
and business partners Corey um is is
really into this stuff and one time I
went over to their house and uh he was
just like Greg I need to tell you about
the toothpaste conspiracy and to most
people they might be like I don't want
to hear about toothpaste like what what
are you talking about but I heard that
in my ears perked up I was like
toothpaste conspiracy I am all ears um
so anyway that's that's how this was on
my radar in the first place and so I got
an ad and I was like oh this is this is
intriguing um and so I looked
around and found a few brands that had
both the typical concentration of
fluoride that you would get from
fluoridated toothpaste and also hydroxy
appeti and as kind of like mentioned up
top when I started talking about this
they work via two slightly different
mechanisms and so I would think that
they would have additive effects um I
and so yeah I I picked up a tube um if
you're listening to this and you would
like and you would like to to brush like
the host of The Stronger by science
podcast and you know approach approach
our our parasocial relationship that way
uh the actual brand I picked up is
called Dr jyn's super paste if you want
to check it out um but anyway yeah yeah
20 2024 I'm going to start taking my
oral hygiene even more seriously and uh
part of that is is trying out new
toothpaste with a cool new active
ingredient and um yeah so if if you also
like your teeth it's something
potentially worth looking into wow
you're the only person I've ever known
to make dentistry and toothpaste
interesting so very impressive feet like
70% of that was just parroting stuff
Cory told me um so fair he he he made it
interesting for me first I'm I'm just
passing along the love okay so uh we're
about to get into the content here but
just some standard plugs up top before
we get into it if you enjoy the show
please like rate subscribe and uh tell
your friends rating us and and liking it
on whatever podcast platform you listen
on really does help us out kind of helps
their their recommendation algorithms
and whatnot um if you're interested in
hiring a virtual coach to help you with
your training and or nutrition Stronger
by science has a great team of coaches
that can help you out uh including Milo
here um one of our very best coaches uh
they are all one of our very best
coaches they're all great uh and Milo is
no exception there you can learn more
about our coaching program at Stronger
by science.com
SL coaching if you want to purchase
supplements uh that are already cheap
and high quality and you want to get
them even cheaper check out bulk
supplements.com use code sbsod at
checkout for an additional 5% off uh if
you're in the market for a premium
nutrition app and who isn't that's
really the hot commodity these days you
should check out macro factor that is
our premium nutrition app uh macr tring
and diet coaching functionality it is
truly excellent uh and you can use code
SPS when signing up to get an extra week
added to your free trial uh if you want
to stay up to date on all of the
research that's relevant to strength and
physique athletes and coaches as it
comes out uh you should check out
monthly applications in
research monthly applications in
strength support uh or mass for short
you can find that at Mass resesarch
review.com uh if you'd like to fully
stay up to date on the stronger by
science extended Universe join our
Facebook group and subreddit uh that is
stronger by science community on
Facebook and reddit.com r/r Stronger by
science on
rdit uh if you want to stay in touch on
another way uh you can sign up to our
newsletter at stronger.com
newsletter uh there will send you high
quality informative content as it is
published if you're if you're worried
that you're going to miss uh new
articles or research spotlights or
whatever sign up to the newsletter and
guess what then you won't miss that
stuff uh and that is like primarily what
we use it for in the interest of full
disclosure sometimes we do send little
pitches and sales emails but very very
rarely that is not the primary purpose
there we're not going to spam you with
that stuff um and last but not least if
you have questions that you'd like us to
answer on the podcast uh you can record
a voice clip and email it to podcast
Stronger by science.com uh please keep
those questions under a minute if
possible so let's get into this episode
as I mentioned up top today I'm joined
by Dr Milo wolf uh and and
so uh Milo my my first question for you
is uh I know you did a small tour of the
US this past summer and so I'm just
curious what was your favorite part of
the trip uh and as a European what was
the most stereotypically American thing
you did like like you you you just do it
and you're like damn this is this is
this is just so so different from
from life back in
Europe man that's a good question so I
think honestly my favorite thing I did
and the most stereotypically American
thing I did were perhaps the same and by
and large that was
eating um so maybe the most
stereotypically American thing I did was
actually in you know good company namely
with yourself and Lindsay I um had some
barbecue like smok House Barbecue the
first time and maybe I think the first
time in my life I'm not 100% sure about
that but it certainly doesn't have as
much of a cultural influence or you
don't find it many places in Europe
really um hey maybe it's because the EU
L crack down on potential cogens but uh
it's just something you don't really
find in Europe and so having uh smoked
barbecue was honestly one of the
highlights I also had other good food
like I think I got to give credit to
it's basic but a bagel New York honestly
like again not a thing you really find
that much in Europe but just very solid
like a good amount of food tasty street
food can complain so honestly like by
and large I would just say eating a
variety of food um what I will say
undisputed champ of fast food to me
right from what I've had and this is a
limited selection mhm Chick-fil-A right
hell yeah just very very very good it's
funny you say that cuz you you live in
the UK and and I do think it's a little
bit funny and does play into stereotypes
a bit that you're like what what was my
favorite thing about America I had some
good food for once uh you know it's it's
it's not just it's not just mushy peas
and beans on toast you guys have
flavor not to mention bread sandwich you
know or toast sandwich is cool I think
oh yeah oh man oh man I forgot about
toast sandwiches God that rocks so uh
yeah if you're not familiar a toast
sandwich is when you make a sandwich but
instead of having the usual uh flavorful
things inside like you might have ham or
you might some greens and maybe some
sauce really all you really need in
there is a piece of toast right like I
think the two slices of bread are
already the good bits we may as well
just have more of them and so by having
that slice of bread in the middle as
well you're really just maximizing on
your returnal investment that's how I
see it and certainly that's how they saw
it during wartime in the UK because they
actually came up with something called
the toast sandwich uh I mean that that
was probably a kind of necessity as the
mother of invention type of thing here's
here is something I don't quite get
about the UK like there there are there
were quite a few things there there were
like wartime kind of like real real
Struggle Bus foods from the US during
like the Great Depression and various
Wars and whatnot that like you can read
about in a history Street book but then
like the war got over or the recession
got over and like food became more
plentiful again and we we simply stopped
eating those things for the most part um
I really I really do want to know why
like toast sandwiches are are still a
thing you know like if all you can
afford is bread and you're like hey I
want to I want to Gussy this up a little
bit feel like I'm still eating a
sandwich like I get it but like but why
why still you know so I it to all you
know to give credit to UK words do I
don't actually think anyone nowadays has
a toast sandwich however we do still
have things like uh beans on toast mhm
which is only one step away from that
which is we take baked beans right some
of the cheapest food you can possibly
get canned food and you say no I'm not
going to have ham on my in my sandwich
or anything delicious I'm just going to
put beans on it right it's it's cheap
it's plentiful it's nutritious I'm going
to put beans on my sandwich and it's
going to be delicious um I think
honestly the poor culinary choices of
the UK are summarized in their
breakfast I think that their breakfast
is a weird combination of like wait wait
wait like like a like a full English
breakfast that is correct yes I I
disagree I disagree so strongly go on
then I I do love a full English I mean I
I don't have anything insightful to add
um I I do I do just like a full English
breakfast I just think that it comes off
as very deconstructed right to the point
of just you put random things on a plate
beans some Tomatoes some mushrooms some
poorly cooked bacon and by the way
crispy bacon is much better than thick
cut uh watery bacon um so that's another
thing that what what is it against
streaky versus slab bacon are those the
terms yeah something like that I mean in
the US basically whenever you go to a
diner you get um crispy be thin strips
of bacon and it's delicious and great
yeah but in the UK when you get a 4ish
breakfast often times you'll just end up
with like a slab of bacon that isn't
Brown in the least and it's just
mediocre and it still tastes good
because often times you know it's smoked
and it's fatty and it'll be fine but you
just have to ask the question why yeah
yeah okay um
so uh that that is that is good I'm I'm
glad you enjoyed the food when you
visited the
um but I I think that we uh we we
probably should um introduce you to the
audience so for for people unfamiliar
with you which uh their Misfortune by
the way uh tell the audience a little
bit about yourself what's your what's
your lifting background what's your
academic background uh what what should
what should people know about Milo wolf
for sure so as you so kindly introduced
me my name is Dr Milo wolf although
doctor is not my first name uh it's
merely the title I was recently
awarded um so my lifting background and
Sports Science Background actually
relates back to strong by science a
little bit so I first started lifting
when I was 13 or 14 years old uh I just
stopped playing soccer you would call it
in the US and it was like ah this team
sport thing isn't really for me anymore
and I'm about to take this push-up and
curls in my room hobby up and lch and go
to a gym so I started lifting R 13 14
initially did all the uh silly things
you could possibly do so was doing a
body part split you know 30 sets of
triceps in one day 30 sets of ABS in a
day past failure all the good stuff um
watching Mike Chang I remember
distinctly good times and doing keto in
rural Austria because I was convinced by
my CH that was how I had lose fat at the
time um so good times really and then
after a year or two things went downhill
and I started reading strength
Theory um so that's when I start started
getting into the science behind lifting
and it went from having a good time
watching Mike
Chang just enjoying life really to
reading about the science and to be
honest I kind of enjoyed it so over the
past next like couple years but still
enjoying life right it's not l so less
so it all went downhill from strength
Theory onwards um there was another
inflection point when it was renamed to
Strong by science but you know just down
was from there really yeah that's that's
totally understandable that that that is
the typical trajectory I think of
someone in our audience you're you're
happy go-lucky you're happy as a clam
and then you discover our stuff and
you're you're much more well informed
but some somehow there's just not as
much light in life anymore just every
everything starts seeming gray
um H we'll we'll work on that in 2024
maybe we'll see we'll see for sure so
started reading strength the at the time
started getting more into the sports
sence side of things um my programming
started becoming less bad which was nice
and around the time I turned 17 which is
when I finished high school I had to
decide hey where do I want to study
after I'm done here and a variety of
things had appeal But ultimately the one
thing I kind of did in my free time
seemed to be lifting and reading about
lifting and so I was like ah okay let me
just pursue this I guess it's pretty fun
so went to the UK I moved from Belgium
to the UK to study I did my undergrad in
sport and exercise science at lur
University which was all well and good
but towards the end of I kind of
realized I hadn't really learned much
about lifting I'd learned a lot about
the basics of physiology like
biomechanics and motor control which was
helpful right more so as and I think
you've you've brought me this analogy
more so is a [__] detector than
anything else where you kind of get a
sense of okay this person saying things
but they don't align with even the most
basic of physiology or biomechanics and
therefore something ain't right yeah you
know yeah so that's what it kind of
helped me with I think and also in just
being able to read most papers and
understand at least kind of what's going
on but then from then on it didn't
really teach me anything with regards to
lifting and I think that's
where I was kind of lost and I was
towards the end of mandad i' done
reasonably well but I was kind of
thinking okay where do I go from here
right I've been doing some coaching for
a while as well so i' had some
experience on that front but I wasn't
100% sure where to go so I TW with the
idea of doing a masters in statistics or
in data science what have you to kind of
give me both a better interpretation of
science but also potentially broader
prospects so if I wanted to do something
else I could always do that right kind
of a uh a wise move or like the the
smart move in that sense yeah I I mean
not to not to throw too much shade on my
own field but like that ju just for just
for uh be being confident in setting
oneself up for Success that may have not
been the worst decision you could have
made uh glad I'm I'm glad you went down
the road you did but it's not the most
portable degree one could have it
certainly isn't it really isn't um but
anyways uh eventually I actually spoke
to Greg here and I asked him oh if I
wanted to do a Masters or PhD and
actually learn about lifting where would
I go what universities have researchers
who research lifting cuz presumably
those universities would be better
positioned to actually tell me about
lifting he gave me some recommendations
uh one of them happened to be within or
a couple of them within the UK and so I
got in touch with Southampton solent
University uh down south in the UK and
initially I was going to apply for a
master's program uh in sports science
but to make sure that I wasn't making a
huge mistake I got in touch with the uh
program I guess the head of the program
right and just email them asking hey my
main interest is lifting will this
actually teach me about lifting and they
got back to me and said no it won't it's
still a very general program program and
to be honest if you wanted to learn
about lifting you'd be much better
served pursuing a PhD and so I said sure
and applied for a PhD there uh put in a
research proposal and got accepted so I
actually didn't do a masters I went
straight from undergrad to a
PhD and so from the year 2020 to 20 3 I
did my PhD in sport Science specifically
I looked at the effects of range of
motion during resistance training so in
the gym how much range of motion do you
lift with do you for example on the
squat do a four range of motion squat
going as deep as you can and all the way
back up or do you do a partial squat for
example a half squat how does that
impact adaptations for example how does
that impact how much muscle growth you
see from that exercise how much strength
you gain that was essentially the topic
of my PhD um and yeah recently finished
successfully defend the PhD as of 3
months ago 2 months ago and yeah here we
are
now this is your your first time on the
podcast your your research uh of very
good chunk of it to this point has been
about uh the impact of of muscle length
and range of motion on hypertrophic
responses so uh I I feel like as as your
first first appearance on the stronger
by science podcast I would be remiss if
that was not the topic that we dug into
here so that that is the main thing
we're going to be chatting about uh in
this episode so um just to kick things
off I'm curious what got you interested
in that topic in the first place there
are you know virtually infinite number
of things that one could uh tackle for
for their PHD research so why range of
motion and muscle length in
particular great question so I'm
actually going to give a shout out to
mass researcher you because around the
time I was applying for Master's
programs in data science statistics and
what have you I was reading a lot of MTH
right like i' had been subscribed to
mass since 2017 when I started my
undergrad undergrad degree and I saw
that you had broken down the systematic
review by Brad shenfeld and Joseph gik
on the effective range of motion during
resistance training on muscley hery mhm
and I was kind of reading this stuff at
the same time as I was making
applications for Ms programs and
phds and I looked at it I was like huh
that's pretty cool uh there's apparently
only Six studies on range of motion and
hypertrophy and there seems to remain
some lack of understanding as to how it
works in some regards at the time we had
four studies in a lower body and two in
the upper body and in the upper body
specifically there was kind of a lack of
consensus right which led the authors to
speculate that maybe in the upper body
in those muscle groups there's a
different relationship with range of
motion compared to lower body right like
if for a lower body you use a full range
of motion you might see more growth but
maybe in the upper body it works
differently where you don't need to use
a for range motion what have you MH cuz
at the time of the two studies that have
been out I think one had found better
hypertrophy with full range em motion
and one have found better hypertrophy
with partial range motion if I'm not
mistaken and so
it just seemed to be an area that was in
need of more evidence to get a clear
picture yeah I I think I think at that
point uh there there was already the
goto study and then the the pinto study
on curls which which were you know which
were kind of weird like it it was it was
strange that there were only two upper
body studies and everything else was
lower body but those those were also two
like full range of motion versus partial
but only in the middle of the range of
motion studies so um you know instead
instead of like going all the way down
or locking out just kind of like staying
in the mid-range which is like an
atypical an atypical model so it's it I
it was it was a little bit interesting
that those that that that was all that
existed for upper body at the time for
sure for sure and I think that's what as
we'll probably find out later in the
episode contri Ed to the lack of clarity
in the findings um anyways that was part
of the reason the other part was at the
time I was uh doing some work for
Renaissance
periodization and one of the big
recommendations they used to make and
still make to the say to an extent was
to use a full range of motion when
lifting for hypertrophy or for muscle
growth
um and myself I was very much employing
this in my own training and in my
coaching practice because I thought the
evidence was pretty solid I kind of as
you really shouldn't be doing uh took
someone on their word without directly
looking at the evidence too closely and
so I was like huh okay well I'm using
for range of motion and everything but
it turns out the evidence there isn't as
rock solid as I thought and like at the
very least there is not enough evidence
yet to have a clear consensus for all
muscle groups all the time for
hypertrophy MH I was like okay well it's
a topic of interest cuz I I see plenty
of people using a partial range motion
plent people using a four range motion I
have no thoughts and there was lack of
evidence so like okay I got to pick a
topic here uh that's the thing with a
PhD I think that a lot of people
initially think they need to do
perfectly right they need to be like
okay I'm going to pick the perfect topic
that I will remain interested in for the
duration of my PhD and be passionate
about and it's going to be awesome I
think that's a very good aspiration to
have but equally at some point you need
to make a decision about what you going
to study and as long as it's topic that
you're reasonably interested in I think
you should be fine M and so I kind of
said okay well look I have a reasonable
interest in this there's a lack of data
let me just go ahead and submit a
proposal for this and yeah that's kind
of how it all started nice nice uh
so can you can you describe your own
research a little bit um and the broader
research around the topic of impact of
of range of motion and muscle length on
hypertrophy outcomes just just to make
sure that the listener has like pretty
pretty solid grounding in this topic
before we delve deeper yeah that's a
great question so I'll give my answers
in a in a few parts I guess the first
part is briefly summarizing what the
research looked like in 20120 when M
that systematic review I just mentioned
came out at the time in the lower body
it seemed pretty clear across four
studies that for range of motion was
better for muscle growth right compared
to partial range motion often often
times in these lower body studies they
use the squat exercise the squad is just
a fat and favorite when it comes to
sports scientists they just love looking
at the squat whether it's because of
transfer to other sports or what have
you but Squad is just the exercise of
choice typically and then within the
upper body they had two studies um which
kind of had mixed results and so we
needed a bit more evidence now at the
time I think they essentially just
looked at range of emotion as being
either full or partial but they didn't
really dig deeper into it they also
didn't put perform a quantitative
synthesis so they didn't perform an
analysis they also didn't look at the
effects of range of motion on different
outcomes like for example strength
outcomes or power outcomes or sport
outcomes and so there was some there was
something missing as far as the range of
motion data went and so a few years
later in 2022
2023 uh in the middle of my PhD we
essentially thought look part of the
thesis it makes sense first of all you
have to do a liter review and so if you
also do a metth analysis that just kind
of fits in neatly right it's a good way
to do it and so I conducted a
metanalysis and systematic review on the
existing literature comparing partial
range of motion to for range of motion
and its effect on hypertrophy strength
power outcomes support outcomes Etc and
essentially here's what happened first
compared to previous analyses we did a
lot more I guess you call it digging or
subgroup analyses and moderator analyses
MH some of which like if you're looking
at a subset of data you're often going
to be looking at like two or three
studies and so you're not going to be
able to say look there's definitely
something happening here but you might
be able say oh maybe there is something
happening here it might be worth
investigating further right some anes
are a bit more tentative than others but
broadly speaking here were the results
of that metth analysis in total we had
around 20 to 25 studies for correctly um
a lot of them looked at strength some of
them looked at Power outcomes about
eight I think at the time looked at
hypertrophy so a bit more data than when
um the Brad sheld Systema came out and
when you just looked at for range of
motion versus partial range of motion
and how that did for different outcomes
like for example for hypertrophy versus
strength versus Power outcomes sport
outcomes all effect sizes leaned in
favor of full range of motion when you
simply dichotomize things by four range
of motion and partial range of motion
but as far as how much of a benefit
there was in favor of four range motion
we're talking about a trivial effect
size of around 0.1 so a trivial effect
size is usually considered between 0 and
0.2 so it was right in the middle of
being a trivial effect size in
statistical terms
right however that's that was
interesting to me first of all for one
reason which is that a previous meth
analysis on the same topic for
hypertrophy had found a pretty big
difference in favor of for range motion
uh because they had only looked at lower
body findings that was a metanalysis by
palis and
colleagues and so I was quite surprised
to find out that ah actually FL range of
motion only seems to have about a 0.1
effect size in favor of it over parti
range of motion even for appr so that
was one finding I kind of had to wrap my
head around keep in mind my background
there was I think for Ranger motions
best mhm and so that was kind of if
anything my bias going into it and so
that was one thing but then things got
both
more both went as predicted but also way
differently than predicted from there so
as I mentioned we then performed some
sub group analyses to look at different
things like different substance data
looking at okay how does how do you
think change when for example we look at
machine only interventions versus free
weights does that play any role that
sort of stuff so two of those things
that we did look at were one specificity
essentially and two the muscle length at
which paral range of emotion was
performed mhm so when I'm talking about
specificity we essentially took strength
power sport outcomes and categorized
them by what range of motion are these
outcomes actually testing right so for
example you're talking about a partial
range of motion one rep max in the squat
and you know you're doing a half squat
for example that would inherently be
more of a partial range of motion
outcome and so if specificity was a
thing you would expect a partial range
of motion group to see better outcomes
than the for Ranger motion group M
likewise certain outcomes didn't really
have a bias either way so for example
isometric tests depending on the joint
angle involved might not really have a
bias towards either a partial range
motion approach or a full range motion
approach so whether you train for R
motion or parti range motion inherently
if specificity even if specificity
impacted results shouldn't really play
too much of a role and then finally
there were outcomes that were more so
biased towards a 4 range motion like for
example a 4 range motion one Earth Max
and so when we categorized outcomes for
strength power sports Etc that way what
we saw is that the range of motion that
you trained in did impact how much of a
benefit did you see in your outcome
essentially when you train with a full
range of motion you saw better for range
of motion gains than if you TR with
partial range of motion likewise when
you TR partial range of motion you saw
better partial range of motion gains
than when you trade with for range of
motion so essentially specificity did
seem to apply to range of motion the
interesting copy out there looking at
the overall twofold one it seems that
full range of motion delivers more of a
benefit to your partial range of motion
performance versus partial range of
motion training will deliver a benefit
to your full range of motion performance
in other words if you do a four range of
squat for example you'll still get
pretty decent gains in your half squat
right but if you did half squats the
carryover or the transfer to your for
range motion Squad might not be quite as
good right so ultimately training
whatever you're trying to get better at
but there will be a greater carryover to
partial range of motion by doing a full
range of motion than is true the
opposite way around if I can just say
something about that I I really don't
find that surprising at all uh like that
bit Ju Just that like Kario over from
Full to partial is better than carryover
from partial to full cuz like with with
full range of motion you are still
training the partial range of motion
just not exclusively you know like uh
the idea of like full squats improving
half squats more than half squats
improve full squats like if you're doing
half squats you're you're not training
the bottom half of the range of motion
which is like kind of where the squat is
the hardest in the first place so I do
find it fairly intuitive that it that
that that that carryover is not going to
be particularly good but like when
you're doing a full squat like you are
also still doing a half Squad like you
go down to half squat depth and then you
just keep going and then you stand up a
little bit and you reach half squat
depth and you keep standing up like the
the partial range of motion is still
like fully circumscribed in the full
range so like I'm not I I I don't I
don't find it surprising that that
carryover is much better than the other
way around I agree entirely and you and
I came to the same conclusion in thesis
I kind of described it as it comes down
to the inclusion versus exclusion of
different ranges of motion when you're
parti range of motion by definition
you'll be excluding some of the range of
motion involved in a four range of
motion outcome right whereas if you're
doing four range of motion you are still
including that par range motion outcome
and so yeah you will still get some
gains there um the other interesting
thing was it seemed like and this is a
lot more tentative but potentially uh
combining full range of motion and a
partial range motion might deliver
similar or slightly better strength
gains compared to just doing a full
range motion even for full range of
motion strength outcomes so there are
now four studies on this topic I believe
that compare sort of only doing full
range of motion walk to doing full range
of motion walk and some partial walk in
there as well right for example you
could do like 75% of your training as
full range of motion squats to
competition depth andbe do 25% of your
training as like half squats right that
would be an approach as an example and
across those four studies generally you
see the same strength outcomes or maybe
slightly better when doing a combination
which kind of lends credibility to the
idea
that what a lot of power power lifters
sorry have been doing for a while
anyways is reasonable enough and that
they have some parti range of motion
training in there and they're probably
not missing out on any strength gains
and they may even see some additional
strength gains as a result of including
some partial range of motion working
there um so that was what kind of
findings as far as strength went and
performance the more interesting
findings to me because uh while I've
competed in pting I also competed in
bodybuilding and while I'm not rushing
to get back on stage for bodybuilding I
do generally train more so for
hypertrophy um so the more interesting
findings I think to a lot of people and
to myself especially and for
transparency when I got these results it
took me a few days to fully digest and I
remember texting a client of mine being
like I must have like inputed the data
wrong during data extraction because
this just doesn't seem right based on
everything like I've seen and heard and
stuff like that doesn't quite strike me
as right um essentially when you broke
down approaches so you have full range
of motion and you have partial range of
motion but when you're looking at
partial range of motion you can break
that down further into whether or not
you were training on average at shorter
muscle lengths compared to four range of
motion or at longer muscle lengths so
when you're doing a full range of motion
let's break it down to halves right one
half will be more so training the
agonists at Short muscle lengths and one
half more so at long muscle lengths MH
now if you were to do bottom half
partials on the squat for example you
would be training on average at longer
muscle lengths for the quads the glutes
the Alors and so forth and so depending
on where you do your partial range of
motion right you may or may not be
training at longer or shorter muscle
lengths compared to the four range of
motion on average right but just staying
in a certain position for most of the
set mhm and so when we wrot broke down
partial ranges of motion into being
either at shorter muscle lengths on
average or at longer muscle length on
average for hypertrophy a different
picture emerged specifically it seemed
like when partials are performed at
Short muscle lengths or shorter muscle
lengths you see worse hypertrophy
compared to for Ranger motion and the
reason why in previous meth analyses and
systematic reviews we had found that
four Ranger motion was better was
probably because the preponderance of
evidence has simply compared short
muscle length partials to a full range
of motion and if short muscle length
partials are inherently worse for
hypertrophy and that's how most Studies
have compared partial range of motion to
full range of motion that's why you'd
see that overall for range of motion
tends to outperform partial range of
motion however when you then compared a
partial range of motion per at longer
muscle lengths to a full range of motion
we actually saw more hypertrophy with a
partial range of motion but performed at
longer average muscle
lengths the cave out there at the time
of the metanalysis we only had three
studies as mentioned earlier with some
subgroup analyses moderator analyses and
so forth you often are dealing with a
pretty small subset of data and you
don't have a ton of confidence regarding
is there really something happening here
or am I just seeing noise in the data
right and so I was cautiously optimistic
about this stuff after a few days of
just being absolutely confused as to how
this had happened um I I guess when you
would have been doing your meta analysis
like there there was what at the time
like the the
Mayo uh hamstring curl study
um like seated versus line hamstring
curl and the Pedrosa quad study and like
that was that was kind of it for like
specifically uh separating out like
short and long muscle length partials so
like probably don't want to like
massively overe extrapolate from two
papers for sure so at the time we
actually looked at uh three studies
which were the pedosa study the work
housing study uh an underrated classic
which had participants do something like
9° of knee extension based on the
schematic mhm uh on the leg press which
is like a super partial range of motion
and finally actually not the myo study
because the myo study didn't actually
compare full range of motion to partial
range of motion just the same range of
motion at different muscle lengths so
that wasn't actually included in our
analysis what we inste included was
actually oh you're you're right I I I
had I had that as like a tab in my mind
as like equated like total angular
displacement but different muscle
lengths which which is like functionally
the same indeed indeed all good the last
study we included was actually the goto
study where if you look at the ranges of
motion involved it is it's kind of in
between a moderate muscle length or like
a Midway partial and like a lengthen
partial M um if you actually just
straight up compare the average joint
angle and muscle length in the partial
group versus the 4in motion group it is
longer in the partial Ranger motion
group but it's very close to being the
same but as far as sort of sort of the
approach we took in categorizing studies
it just fell into the length and
partials group I think that's it's more
of a length and partial and is a short
and partial to say the least so that's
the three studies that we included but
in the process of writing up the
discussion obviously there were a lot of
studies that weren't included in the Met
analysis because they didn't directly
compare a full range of motion to a
partial range of motion and in fact at
the time I think there
were seven or eight studies comparing
the same range of motion at different
muscle lengths the myo study you
mentioned earlier is one of them where
for example in the myo study they
compared doing the same range of motion
of knee flexion so of flexing your knees
on the seated light curl versus the Ling
like C now because the hamstrings and a
few other muscle groups are biarticular
and actually cross at the hip your hip
position during the seated l c and the
ly l c will impact the muscle length of
the hamstrings and potentially the
gillus muscle for examp example and so
while you're doing the same range of
motion the same degrees of knee flexion
in both the seated and line light curl
in the seated light curl you would be
lengthening three heads of the
hamstrings more the biceps foror long
head the semiosis and the sem mosis
whereas during L like curl you might be
lengthening the gillus muscle more
because it's hip flexor when your hips
are extended it's being lengthened more
and so the same range of motion but
different muscle lengths and broadly
speaking at the time I think we had
seven or eight studies we have nine
studies now we have had these studies
comparing the same range of motion at
different muscle lengths and very
consistently within this data as well
nowadays we have nine studies eight of
which have found more hypertrophy
broadly speaking after partials at
longer muscle lengths compared to
partials at shorter muscle lengths
likewise in the discussion I also noted
that we had at the time I think also
five studies comparing isometric
contractions at different muscle lengths
so either at shorter or longer muscle
lengths just an isometric hold and again
consistently crosses five step studies
it seemed to be the case that doing
those isometrics at lower muscle lengths
led to more hypertrophy compared to
Shorter muscle lengths and so while I
was initially honestly taken back by the
findings with regards to hypertrophy
when you sort of subdivided it into
partials at Short muscle lengths or long
muscle lengths and how that compared and
sized up to 4 in motion when you
actually take a step back and look at
the overall evidence there's about 20 or
25 studies comparing different muscle
length training and measuring
hypertrophy and very consistently Within
that overall data it seems to be the
case that longer muscle length training
is better and it just so happens to be
that when you compare longer muscle
length partials as kind of a vehicle for
that almost to a for range em motion it
also seems to be potentially better for
hypertrophy so since this met analysis
has been published there have been two
new studies one is only conference
abstract so who knows if it'll ever come
out so don't don't take this as a gospel
right it may be that they just presented
at a conference and it'll never come out
but I'll include that for the sake of
discussion here so two studies one of
which only is conference abstract but
when you add those into the
aforementioned three studies we have
five studies comparing a four in motion
to link partials amongst these five
studies four found more hypertrophy in
some regard not necessarily all Sites
but in some regard more hypertrophy with
a length and partial approach or longer
muscle length partial range motion and
one has found no difference and the last
one is a study by work housing
colleagues and so overall at this stage
with having 20 or 25 studies comparing
shorter muscle length training to longer
muscle length training for hypertrophy
and very consistently finding hey longer
muscle length training seems beneficial
for
hypertrophy it's not an open and shut
case but it's getting to the stage where
it seems to apply cross a variety of
muscle groups it seems to apply across a
variety of sort of contraction modes
whether you're talking about isometrics
or partial R of motion at different
muscle lengths or four range of motion
versus paral range of
motion it seems like a relatively
generalizable principle at this point to
say that longer muscle length training
will lead to more hypertrophy than
shorter muscle length training the final
not I give is as far as magnitude goes I
think with any new phenomenon people are
newly researched phenomenon rather um
people are very quick to assume this is
going to be revolutionizing your gains
and for the sake of integrity and
transparency this won't revolutionize
your gains in all likelihood we're
talking about a difference of like based
on some right well it's been a good
episode thanks for coming on uh no I'm
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding keep
going uh based on some analysis we ran
we're talking about a difference in
hypertrophy between 4 in of motion and
length partials of like 5 or 10% it's
honestly not going to be noticeable to
you in a likelihood like even if you
went from only for range of motion to
only length partials there's a good
chance you'd never be able to tell the
difference so it's worth
noting what does the research directly
tell us about the mechanism here like is
there a like super like robustly
wellestablished
um like direct mechanism to explain
those findings or is is that something
for future research to work out yeah so
unfortunately we don't fully know yet
um very few of these intervention
studies that compare for example length
and partials to for motion and what have
you really even measure mechanistic data
right like study by Goo and colleagues
the one I mentioned earlier that one for
example measured blood lactate and
oxygenation but that's a rarity
generally it's not even that and so we
are far from having any sort of
consensus as to what the mechanism
exactly is here now you could kind of
grasp at straws and try and extrapolate
and generalize from some of the stretch
literature we have right so we have data
in mostly animal models and mostly with
durations of stretching that are
essentially incomparable to some of this
stuff MH so when we're talking about
stretching studies we're often talking
about at least like an hour day of
stretching uh that's kind of like the
minimum in human studies relatively
commonly used like an hour or so a day
and in animal studies often we're
talking about around the clock and so if
you were to take those studies where yes
they are being kept at long muscle LS
the whole time and so you might assume
that there's some mechanisms in common
there absolutely might be some
mechanisms common but it's very
important to remember that a we're
talking about mostly animal studies B
the durations and intensity of exposure
are very different right when we're
talking about stretching we're talking
about being kept at the longest possible
muscle lengths at for humans often the
relatively low intensity for animals
often a relatively high intensity um but
we're talking about often hours a day of
stretching versus an extra 30 seconds
being spent at long muscle lengths
during lifting if you're say using
length and partials versus 4 range
motion so assuming there's some sort of
dose response relationship there with
the mechanism causing growth during
stretching and you know as you spend
half an hour you get a bit of growth
when you spend an hour you get a bit
more growth if that were really the
mechanism at play here I'm not sure we
would see it with durations of exposure
you know spending an extra 30 seconds
extra in a lengthen position across a
whole session When comparing lengthen
partials to 4 in motion it just doesn't
seem likely and to an extent I've
compared it before to comparing the
adaptations or the mechanism involved
between the adaptations you get from
cardio or like running for example or
endurance work which often involves like
20 30 hours of exposure a week versus
for example lifting there are different
modes of exercise alog together and so I
think we're relatively far away at at
this point from a clear mechanism um it
may also not be that there is one clear
mechanism often times I think with
physiology it's not uncomon to have
redundancy and different Pathways kind
of overall causing more hypertrophy from
one approach versus another
um all that to say no we don't currently
have a clear mechanism as to why lower
muscle lengths cause more hypertrophy
potentially yeah I I I definitely agree
with that takeaway I um one of the one
of the things about this topic that
frustrates me and I assume frustrates
you as well is this is a subject that
has over the last year or so gotten like
I think relatively popular as like a
topic of discussion on social media and
whatnot uh and and just across the web
more broadly and when most people talk
about it I I very frequently see like
very very strong statements about like
why these findings exist um which which
often come down to like oh it's it's all
just about stretch and like the stretch
under load increases um muscle link
uh and and like that's the main
mechanism or um it's all
about one one that I see Pop Up from
time to time is like Titan related
signaling because like when Titans
lengthen there's like um like KY a
binding domains but like as far as I'm
aware we're still not totally sure what
those do um or that it's all just about
like total tension like when you go to
longer muscle links you have an increase
passive tension within the muscle and so
like total tension is higher but like I
don't know like my my read of all of
that is that one those are all potential
mechanisms but you you you kind of need
to connect things right like you need to
run a study that
simultaneously um like it has to use an
experimental model where you test the
impact of different ranges of motion on
outcomes and then within that same study
you investigate mechanistic explanations
for the outcomes that you observed
within the same sample that you observe
those outcomes in so you know you you
could say like and and going back to the
comparison to the stretching literature
you know you could hypothesize hey we
have this entirely separate body of
literature that finds hypertrophy after
um after stretching
interventions uh you can't then say
therefore that is what is explaining
these long muscle length training
findings because you know like there
there's well I mean if if we wanted to
take it a step deeper I don't think
we're even sure on like the precise
mechanism by which stretching causes
hypertrophy in those studies like you
know you you need to go one step further
down the rabbit hole You You observe
that the stressor of stretching causes
some hypertrophy but we don't know like
mechanistically why that is uh but yeah
like you you so I guess it's still like
Two Steps From establishing that but
yeah you can't look at the stretching
literature and say stretching causes
hypertrophy training at longer muscle
links that's kind of like a stretch
therefore that is what is causing
greater hypertrophy here like you you
would need to like observe some sort of
like mechanistic explanation in the
same like like within the same study of
the same sample Where You observe those
results with a particular experimental
model and yeah like I I just uh I
haven't seen that and like the the
passive tension one is well in uh sorry
I'm I'm on on my [__] here uh really
quick the other thing that like really
irks me about the stretching explanation
of like oh like it's it's all just about
stretch is like a pretty decent number
of the studies here very notably don't
stretch the muscles involved you know
like if if you wanted to talk
about um I don't know let's say let's
say like the the Bloomquist study on
squats where you're comparing squatting
from uh 0 to 60° range of motion uh uh
like knee flexion range of motion to 0
to 120° knee flexion range of motion not
like not everyone is going to feel a
stretch in their quads if they go to
120° of knee flexion but like some will
you know you you could credibly look at
that and say oh yeah like they they put
a stretch on these folks quads and you
load that and you observe more growth
than training at 0 to 60° range of
motion like okay cool like you could you
could maybe make that argument there but
then like several of the studies just
use like knee extension exercises
through 0 to 90° range of motion and I
mean if you're listening bust out of
[__] retractor like bend your knees
to 90° of knee flexion and tell me if
you feel a stretch in your quads I
unless you've
recently like had a knee injury where
you've been in a brace for several weeks
and you're now working on regaining
range of motion in your knee like if
that is you yeah maybe you feel a
stretch in your quads when you Flex to
90° of knee flexion [__] no one else
is experiencing a stretch there so there
there are enough obser D instances of
more hypertrophy at longer muscle links
in situations where longer muscle links
do not coincide with any sort of like
significant stretch occurring that like
I feel like you you can't you you can't
in good faith lean on that as like a
full explanation for or even like a
primary explanation for these findings
um and then the other one is like the
the total tension idea of like oh like I
I think I think a lot of this just comes
from bad assumptions about causes of
hypertrophy and this might be another
topic for another day that would be good
to to dig into but I I think that
there's like a strain of like what I
like to call tension reductionism that's
floating around out there like the idea
that mechanical tension is the only
thing that matters for hypertrophy and T
and tacitly kind of building on that uh
as tension increases it like more or
less linearly increases growth so like
if you can increase tension on something
that will like increase the the
hypertrophic signaling response and so
the the idea building off of that is
like when a muscle is stretched um like
obviously you you can like actively
recruit and contract a muscle that's
like active tension generation and
generally your ability to actively
generate tension decreases at long
muscle lengths just because you you can
get fewer uh actin and mein cross
Bridges forming as sarum miror links
increase but you also have like um stiff
semi-elastic connective tissue running
through your muscles that when a muscle
is put in stretch the tension generated
by that tissue basically to keep your
muscle from like tearing off the bone uh
starts going up and
the the for not every muscle but for a
lot of muscles like theoretically where
your total muscle tension is the highest
would be like right before your muscle
tears all the way off the
bone and at that point it's like almost
no passive t or almost no active tension
and entirely passive tension but like
the the capacity
to um yeah depending on your perspective
generate or withstand passive tension is
is quite High um and so you know uh the
the idea here is like well tension is
really the thing and so if you can get
passive tension really really high like
total tension will be higher therefore
it will be better for
hypertrophy and
like that that's just not how these
experimental models work and in some
cases you you could look at some of
these results and say like hey in the
long in the longer muscle length Group
total tension would have been higher in
that group than the shorter muscle
length group um like the there there was
the seated versus line leg curl study by
Mayo that we've alluded to a couple
times like it would fall uh it would
fall like under that umbrella cuz like
the
hamstrings do have like pretty
tremendous capacity to generate passive
tension and if you look at like modeling
research you would get like quite a bit
of that um in like a seated leg curl
compared to a line leg curl like full
knee extension Plus 90° of hip flexion
like that that puts your hamstrings at
long enough lengths that you're you're
getting pretty significant passive
tension generation there but then like
the quads for instance I mean the the
total tension generated by the quads is
the highest at like 60 70 degrees of
knee flexion like if if
that's if it if it just came down to
Total tension like a lot of these
studies are on the quads in particular
particular and I feel like the research
on the quads like pretty much falsifies
the idea that it all just comes down to
Total tension with like passive
mechanical tension being like a really
big thing cuz like yeah like I I don't I
don't know what to say like you you you
generate more total knee Flex or knee
extension torque uh including both
active and passive tension at 70° of
knee flexion than 110 like [__]
everyone does like tension is higher at
shorter muscle links for the quads yet
we see more hypertrophy with longer
muscle links so yeah I don't know like I
I it it frustrates me because I do see a
lot of people very confidently throwing
out mechanisms and as someone who does
know this area of research pretty well
like I look at them and I'm like dude if
like if you actually read this stuff you
wouldn't be making the statements you're
making as confidently as you are
because um you know it's it's not
impossible that those things are
possibly like potential contributors but
like one one of multiple potential
contributors but like the the idea that
that those are the exclusive
contributors to this phenomenon I think
is like fully falsified within the
research but people just act like it's
not and it it it I feel like it's
gaslighting almost cuz here here's the
thing here's the thing like when I see
someone making a statement confident
enough and I see other people who are
like who I think are like generally
relatively bright um kind of like
boosting that and being like Oh yeah
like this is good stuff I'm like am I
the am I the crazy one here you know um
but I'm not I think I think a lot of
people really don't know the research in
this area particularly well and some of
those other things like they they feel
like they're right it's like oh yeah
like tension that's important oh and
yeah like we do see hypertrophy with
stretch sometimes like yeah that so yeah
like it it makes sense but then they
don't really like dig into the research
deep enough or think about it enough to
realize that like no that's that's
actually like kind of stupid cuz like
the idea that either of those things is
like the exclusive
mechanism yeah it's it's not just that
it's it lack support like I I feel like
that idea is just fully falsified at
this point I agree fully um okay I think
the that that would have been awkward if
noted um I think the tension
reductionism is a big one and I think in
general the uh haste with
which some individuals in the industry
are like or some camps rather are eager
to establish a model before we even have
the data in place to make it worthwhile
is odd so as you mentioned it's a big
inclination nowadays to pinpoint the
mechanism as being passive tension
right in reality the evidence isn't
quite there to support that yet who
knows maybe it will turn out to be the
case that this is in fact the only
mechanism but until that evidence is
there the
um the Quasi obsession with trying to
fit every stud's findings into this box
of like okay makes total sense because
of passive tension or of tension and you
know oh what's that there's some data on
for tension for example um lactate
presence stimulating hypertrophy andp
penalty attension well there's got to be
some reason I can explain that way with
so essentially I think the over
insistence with forming a model too
early can lead people astray in their
understanding of stuff um especially
because I think if you have a certain
lens that you like to look at research
through
you end up discording things that you
shouldn't be discording as far as
ignoring certain studies or what have
you when in reality physiology can be
messy it may not just be one mechanism
at play and if you just look at it
throughout one lens you might be tempted
to discard certain findings and I think
it's made evident as well by look
different muscle groups have different
length tension relationships right we
don't even have a perfect understanding
of these yet but they do and yet even
with that being the case it is very
consistently the case across a variety
of muscle groups including the triceps
the biceps the calves the quads the
hamstrings the glutes that longer muscle
length training leads to more
hypertrophy right and these muscle
groups have or at least in some
instances has led to more hypertrophy
indeed Ju Just to just to soften that a
little bit for sure um but in general
the literature like let's compare this
to other fields of empirical evidence uh
within lifting
volume relative intensity so how close
to failure you train if you look at just
individual studies we get meta analytic
estimates of
effects the data on range of motion is
similarly if not more consistent I find
in terms of a study finding more
hypertrophy with say a higher volume
verus a lower volume with range of
motion and different muscle length
training it's honestly the degree of
consistency is remarkable um it's just
an observation but I think it is worth
noting yeah no I I I I definitely agree
with that like
the volume to some extent but like
definitely proximity to failure like the
IND individual study results are all
over the place but yeah like with with
uh range of motion and like muscle links
and
hypertrophy I mean out of a pretty out
of a pretty decent a pretty decently
sized body of literature at this point
you have maybe what like three four
maybe five studies that don't conform to
the general Trend which I don't know is
is more consistency than you tend to see
in applied Sport Science type
research um so just uh just one one last
quick question before we take a quick
little ad Break um just staying on the
topic of of mechanisms here for a second
if if you you just had to take a stab at
it and like you you don't need like
citations for this or anything ju this
is just like purely gut level although
if if there is some like mechanistic
stuff that I'm unaware of please please
enlighten me but um if you had to take a
stab at it what what do you suspect the
the primary mechanism is or mechanisms
are like you know even if some of this
stuff isn't established just on kind of
like a gut level where do you like what
like what what do you think explains
these
findings yeah so I think the most likely
explanation and this might be a c out
because it is directly relying on
outcomes we've actually measured and
then a little bit of sort of imagination
I guess which is the case for all these
mechanistic explanations but I think the
the one I find most likely is one thing
you consistently see within the range of
motion data is that longer muscle length
training leads to more overall
hypertrophy not in every study but
reasonably consistently but that seems
to be more pronounced at more distal
sites of measurement so when you're
measuring hypertrophy you can either
look at whole muscle hypertrophy or you
can look at Regional hypertrophy how
does hypertrophy differ at different
areas of a muscle at more proximal areas
closer to its origin point or at more
distal areas closer to its insertion
point what you do consistently see is
that more distal points closer to the
insertion site of a muscle for example
for the quads more distal would mean
closer to the knees it just means
further away from the center of the body
essentially whichever insertion point
you're talking about and consistently
with range of motion data longer muscle
length training preferentially increases
hypertrophy of distal areas so for the
quads closer to the knee for the biceps
closer to the Elbow what have you and so
to me it doesn't strike me as altogether
unreasonable to think hey maybe during
longer muscle length training those
areas of the muscle have to contribute
to more Force production to the movement
or get activated more readly and there
is a line of research by wakah and
colleagues I believe I could be I could
be confusing wakar and colleagues on
ogasawara I have read both papers and my
head I I I I believe it's wakahara there
we go um there's like three studies
looking at activation as measured via
transverse relaxation MRI as opposed to
surface CMG and they did find a
relationship between activation of
different areas of a muscle during
different exercises and hypertrophy of
that area of the muscle and so maybe
those distal areas of a muscle simply
get activated to a greater extent during
longer muscle length training and
therefore see more hypertrophy at this
stage because it does rely on hey we
actually measured hypertrophy areas and
we see that there's more hypertrophy in
this area that to me seems reasonably
intuitive but equally um far from
settled as regards that being the
definitive mechanism that's how I'm
studing moment yeah I I think I mean I I
think I think that would make sense that
that would that would certainly be a
very tidy explanation and for what it's
worth that would be I think one of the
more feasible things for if if someone
is listening to this and they also want
to do a uh a a a doctoral thesis on
muscle length
training some some mechanistic stuff
would be nice to see and this and and
the reason I say that is like I think
this would be one of the more feasible
ones to look into cuz like you can you
can do Regional EMG analysis like you
know like quads we very reliably see
this effect in quads and like you could
just have like three different sets of
electrodes like some at a more proximal
sight some middle some more distal and
just see like do we see greater distal
EMG with long with long muscle length
training than like shorter muscle length
training and then run the study and like
verify that you do still see like one
greater hypertrophy and two greater like
disproportionate distal hypertrophy in
the sample that you collected the EMG
data in like that that see that seems
like a pretty feasible research project
and one that um yeah like it I I would
like that to be the mechanism just
because like I feel like that could be
established within the next year if
someone had interest in doing that study
but something like relating to signaling
Cascades Associated like the Titan kyes
binding sites I mean that's a feasible
study for someone to do if they're doing
research in one of maybe like four labs
in the
world and for everyone else good luck
like you you just don't have the
equipment to do that study I agree with
that the one thing I'll say and this is
not to be a party po Cooper but I think
we're we're both aware that sort of
surface EMG and hypertrophy with a
length there is a lot weaker than most
people realize and I think this is
actually what a study by Plotkin and
colleagues recently tried to do so they
compared squatting to doing hip thrusts
and measured hypertrophy of the quads
glutes hamstrings adductors but one
thing they did as part of the study
design was they actually measured EMG of
different areas of the quads hamstrings
glutes I think mainly the glutes if I
Rec correctly as far as um EMG of
different areas of the glutes during the
hip thrust versus The Squat and then
they try to see okay well we measured
these the EMG value or the activation of
different muscle groups at Baseline
before we actually have participants
train do the values that we see for
Activation ofer CMG before the study
actually correlate to how much muscle
growth they see across the study doing
these exercises at different sides
within the muscle and what have you and
basically there were next to no
correlations or association between
surface EMG taken at Baseline and
hypertrophy with areas or different
muscles whether you're talking within a
muscle like within the glutes at
different sites or between muscles like
for example you saw great quad EMG
during the hip thrust but then you
didn't necessarily see great quad
hypertrophy during the hip thrust so I
think surface EMG might be it's tempting
because it's a convenient thing to
measure but I'm not sure it's depending
on how you apply it may not be the best
way to do that yeah I this would be too
big of a diversion but I do I do think
that there are some some methodological
considerations there like for sure so I
I feel like a lot of it would come down
to kind of like how you normalized
things especially when you're dealing in
particular with like biomechanically
dissimilar movements um cuz like a
certain EMG
value there's I mean there there are
potentially issues with like
generalizing EMG values to
like to like necessarily imply muscle
activation but like those those
considerations become larger and larger
as fewer things are like standardized or
like more things differ between
exercises um cuz like you could you so
like range of motion is is like pretty
important here because you could have
like the the EMG values associated with
full muscle recruitment differ based on
range of motion so you you very well
could see like Peak EMG values in a in
an ex exercise that loads muscles
through a particular range of motion but
that higher EMG value than some other
exercise that like primarily loads the
same muscle through a different range of
motion like it it could be lower in the
other exercise but like actual motor
unit recruitment is higher just because
like the EMG value associated with like
full motor unit recruitment can like
differ based on range of motion and so
for for like squats versus hip thrust
that is like that is kind of an apples
to oranges comparison um and like I'm
I'm not faulting the researchers for
selecting those two exercises but just
saying like that
is that that is a situation where I
would expect EMG to not be particularly
informative whereas um you know
like just knee extensions through two
different ranges of motion particularly
if you're doing something to like
normalize EMG Val like cuz like you can
you can do a EMG angle curve trace and
so like you could you could compare not
just like mean and Peak EMG values but
like EMG at like different parts in the
range of motion if you did like 0 to 60
versus 0 to 120 like you could you could
match up those traces so that you're
comparing Apples to Apples with like the
0 to 60
comparison um
and even even kind of like
normalize whatever whatever we're we're
not we're not designing that study right
now now like yes I acknowledge I
acknowledge the weaknesses of EMG but I
do yeah like I I I think that it it is
it could probably be like contextually
useful if it was a simple enough study
design with enough variables controlled
and I wouldn't I wouldn't necessarily
look at a squat and hip thrust
comparison and say that that like throws
too much cold water on the idea that EMG
could be a use ful proxy
um but I'm I'm also not surprised that
it wasn't a particularly useful proxy in
that context just because like the two
exercises are so biomechanically
dissimilar no for sure and I think
another proxy that's kind of gten some
attention recently and again somewhat
mixed data is muscle swelling acutely
and whether or not that correlates with
long-term hypertrophy but yeah I think
that mechanistic research that tries to
look at some Pro y of um activation or
predictor of hypertrophy might be a good
Avenue for future
research all right uh so in the second
half of this episode we will dig more
into some of the claims made about long
muscle length training and some of the
controversies and open points of
discussion surrounding the topic but for
now let's take a quick ad
break
all right and we're back uh ready to
kick off the second half of this episode
so um Milo it's it's been claimed i'
I've seen people saying that certain
muscle groups don't grow more when
trained at long muscle lengths and kind
of the two muscles I see uh invoked the
most frequently uh when making that
claim are the biceps and triceps and uh
so I'm curious uh well I'm not Cur I'm
asking for the sake of the audience
because I think some of them might be
curious I think I know the answer but uh
why why do you think people make that
claim and uh what what does the research
say on the topic and and what what do
you think about the idea that like we
either already know or can reliably
predict which muscles will or won't grow
more from training at long muscle links
so
the inclination to say that certain
muscle groups won't respond to longer
muscle Link Training to me seems to stem
as a downstream consequence of
reductionism once again where if you
assume that passive tension for example
is the only mechanism at play and you
see that for example the biceps and
triceps don't experience much passive
tension in a given exercise or by being
lengthened more what have you then you
might assume okay well they don't
benefit benefit from normal length
training because the mechanism that's a
play here isn't going to cause an
additional amount of
hypertrophy now I think that's all well
and good but
equally the most useful studies in
answering applied questions of is this
going to grow more muscle or ultimately
going be the studies that actually
measure hypertrophy from different
things because when you're relying
entirely on mechanistic rationals you
can often be led two diametrically
opposing viewpoints right so if for
example you think that passive tension
is the only thing that matters you might
assume that for example the biceps
triceps May benefit less so from L musle
length training right whereas if you're
going off the Assumption you know that
potentially certain muscle groups do
respond better on account of some other
mechanistic variable then you could come
to the opposite conclusion and depend
depending on your framework they could
both be warranted rationally speaking
but if the direct studies actually
measuring hypertrophy don't seem to
align with what you predicted then maybe
you relying on the wrong mechanisms or
maybe you're assuming there's only this
mechanism at play when there isn't and
so I think whenever you're asked the
question of does intervention a or
intervention B lead to more hypertrophy
or better outcomes looking at studies
that directly compare the two and
measure your outcome of Interest should
be the first recourse then you can look
at mechanistic as a means to explain
away the findings or potentially to
inform future studies or just to form a
more thorough understanding of
phenomenon but you always have to look
at the actual studies measuring
hypertrophy first in this case we have
now three studies on the triceps and I
believe we have two studies we have a
variety of studies on the biceps but
depends on whether you include studies
for example there was still you're
comparing incline curls to preacher
curls where essentially you're comparing
the same range of motion but you're
you're comparing one exercise at the
incline curl that has a longer muscle
length for the biceps long head cuz the
shoulder behind you it's sort of
overextended and therefore the long
headed biceps is more lengthened but the
resistance curve is more so biased to
being difficult in the shortened
position so as you flex your elbow to
the top of the rep rly the lift gets
harder and harder whereas in the
preacher curl you kind of have the
opposite situation where because the
biceps well the upper arm is and the
shoulder are flexed the long head of the
biceps is more so shortened however as
far as the resistance curve goes you
have the most difficulty in the movement
when the forearm is parallel to the
ground or when your biceps are
reasonably lengthened and so certain
studies like those do help to inform
this as well but by and large we have
three studies on the triceps comparing
longer muscle length training to Shorter
muscle length training and two studies
in the biceps to my knowledge um
comparing different muscle length
training or different ranges of motion
in the biceps in the triceps we have a
study by Stak colleagues which compared
push Downs to overhead extensions with
overhead extensions actually being
performed in the sort of most lengthened
position two push Downs being performed
also with 90° of elbow range of motion
so same range of motion just a different
shoulder position and because the
triceps are mono articular for the most
part so the lateral and medial head only
crosses the elbow their muscle length
shouldn't change during push Downs
versus overhead extensions but the long
head of the triceps does cross the
shoulder and so if you're doing an
overhead extension the long head will be
more lengthened as a result compared to
a push down so in this study they
compared overhead extensions as a more
lengthened exercise to push Downs as a
more shortened exercise and broadly
speaking they didn't find a difference
in hypertrophy um between the overhead
extension and the push down if you read
into it and squint just right you can
see that nominally uh the differences do
lean in favor of the overhead extension
Group which when you consider that as an
overall estimate we're talking about
potentially as little as 5 or 10%
difference in growth it may be that hey
there was a difference in the study but
it simply wasn't picked up through the
use of null hypothesis significance
testing which does avoid lot of type one
errors or false positives but it does
also often result in false negatives
whereby you miss a result that might
have been there well it it does um with
with with that study in particular the
Sasaki study there were like I think
slightly
conflicting results with muscle
thickness measures versus uh
cross-sectional area measures as well
like I I could see I could see someone
making an argument in in either
Direction with this one honestly cuz
like well I don't know I don't know like
the the regional hypertrophy responses
do conform well with like the rest of
the literature here um but with with the
exception of generally what we tend to
see is long muscle length training
causes the same or maybe slightly more
hypertrophy at proximal and and middle
sites than short muscle length training
and quite a bit more at distal
sites uh with the cross-sectional area
um results in stasak in particular you
did see nominally more distal
hypertrophy with long muscle length
training but you you saw like
considerably more proximal hypertrophy
with short muscle length training so
kind of like yeah like like the broad
Contours of the relationship were
similar in that you see a large a larger
Advantage distal than proximal with long
muscle length training but with this one
it did it did seem like short muscle
length training was actually better
proximal than long muscle length
training was was for the cross-sectional
area findings and then the muscle
thickness findings were I I I kind of
agree with your characterization there
where if if you squinted those there
weren't there weren't any significant
differences but kind of the nominal
differences favored um long muscle
length training for both of the sites
they assessed there so h i i i do
personally view that one as a relatively
ambiguous finding um like the regional
hypertrophy findings were very much in
line with what we'd expect um from the
the rest of the literature like that the
broad pattern but I don't necessarily
know that I would lead on that one um as
evidence of like more kind of global
hypertrophy with long muscle length
training yeah no that that makes a ton
of sense um and I do think this is one
of the rare instances where again if you
squint a little bit you can see that
shorter muscle length training led to
more proximal growth this is a
relatively rare finding but it does seem
to lend Credence again to the sort of
overall Contour of the relationship as
you mentioned that hey longer muscle
length training seems to be more
beneficial at more distal sites not so
much approximal sites MH so let study
one and incidentally the only study on
triceps that hasn't found a benefit to
lower muscle length training the other
two are the study by Goo and colleagues
which again it's sort of in the middle
of the full range of motion the partial
range of motion kind of did um roughly
half reps in the middle of the range of
motion but if you're categorizing it
simply into is it a shortened partial or
a lengthen partial it is still a little
bit more lengthened than a 4 range of
motion would have been and then the
third study would be the study by myo
and colleagues which was not exactly the
same design as the study of asaki
colleagues but relatively similar so the
ranges of motion involved were
relatively similar but
the essentially the overhead extension
group was training in a slightly less
lengthened position in the myo group in
the myo study sorry and so we're talking
about a relatively similar study to the
stas study overall um within both the
goo study and the Mayo study on the
triceps we did find more hypertrophy by
large with the partial range motion
approach versus a for range motion
approach and so when you're kind of
synthesizing all three studies I would
say that you're dealing
with a not ideal data because um with
the goto St specifically it's not really
a strict comparison of a length and
partial to a 4ange motion so if you
wanted to merely answer the question of
is lengthen trading better than shorten
trading or do the triceps benefit from
lengthen trading then it's not an ideal
set of studies um so I can't say this is
an open shut case but we are saying that
there are three studies of those three
two have shown a benefit in terms of
muscle growth to length and training and
one has found by and large no real
difference um this is kind of in line
with the rest of the evidence I would
say the rest of the evidence is more
consistent generally but you know if you
have only 10 studies one of them or two
of them might turn out to be non-
significant and it doesn't necessarily
mean that there is no effect it could
just be variance associated with a
relatively small sample size that
totally happens and it doesn't
necessarily mean that there is no effect
so that's kind of my take on the tricep
data and biceps biceps wise we have two
studies
uh we have a study by pinto and
colleagues if I'm not mistaken that was
the first one and we have a study by uh
Pedro and colleagues their second study
on range of motion and finally depending
on how you count it we could also
include the study by zabita cord
colleagues that I mentioned earlier that
was the one comparing the inine CW to
the preacher CW um but let's focus on
Pinto colleagues and oh I I was I was
thinking uh Sato as well oh sat as well
correct yes i' forgot about that one yep
correct um so actually can you head us
off with s because I've forgotten some
of the details on that one uh yeah it
was it was unilateral bicep curls it was
uh comparing two different partial
ranges of motion so uh 130 to 80° of
elbow flexion so that's the long muscle
length and 0 to 50 that's uh that's
short muscle length no no since since
since it's normalized deflection it it
would be inverse but whatever you get
the point two two groups training
training through a total 50 degrees
range of elbow flexion one long muscle
length one short muscle length um doing
unilateral bicep curls assessed muscle
thickness at 50 60 and 70% of humorous
length um and by and large
finding pretty much what you expect um
more more hypertrophy with long muscle
length training and in particular in the
more distal sites than the more proximal
sites yeah I mean that sounds um like
what I recall now that you're mentioning
it it does come back to mind a lot more
um the other two studies I can think of
are the one by pin colleagues where they
compared both of them used the preacher
curl um the one by pinto and colleagues
looked at a full range em Motion versus
a partial range em motion
um now as far as hypertrophy went they
found that there were no real
differences between two groups so
whether they used a 4 in motion or
partial range motion there was similar
hypertrophy the important thing here is
that the partial range of motion group
did train on average at shorter muscle
lengths and the four range of motion
group so it was a short muscle length
partial essentially and the full in
motion group trained on average at
longer muscle lengths and again if you
look at the results nominally and not
just significance wise there were
nominally in favor of the for rang of
motion or the long muscle length group
but this one study did not find a
significant difference between the for
range of motion and partial range of
motion group S one um the final study
the one by Pedro and colleagues compared
the same range of motion but simply
performed at different muscle lengths so
again we're talking about the preacher
Cur and they were either performing the
bottom half of the rep where the biceps
would be more lengthened or the top half
of the rep where the biceps would be
more shortened and they measured
hypertrophy at um 50 and 70% of humorous
length so a more proximal and a more
distal site and they looked at
cross-sectional area and by and large
hyy outcomes were more favorable in the
group doing the bottom half partials
compared to the top half partials um the
overall or summated cross-sectional area
increases were similar between groups so
not statistically different um but when
it came to the 70% site so again the
more distal site they did see more
hypertrophy in the length and partial
group compared to the shorten partial
group so I guess when you kind of
synthesize these three studies the pinto
study the sadow study and the P study
it's kind of a similar story as with the
triceps where the pinto study didn't
find a difference uh between a four
Ranger motion or kind of longer muscle
length training and a partial range of
motion but again nominally it was in
favor of the longer muscle length group
in the S study it seemed to be in favor
of the longer muscle length condition
and finally in the pedosa study in the
more distal side we did see a benefit to
L mus length group but in the more
proximal site there was no difference so
it seems to
conform pretty neatly to the rest of the
evidence in that it seems to be hey
longer muscle length training
predominantly helps with hypertrophy at
more distal sites it potentially helps
out more proximal sites but the effect
may be more less pronounced essentially
um but the shape of the relationship as
far as how it impacts Regional
hypertrophy the direct directionality of
the relationship as far as is lower
muscle length creating better for
approach Fe or Worse both of those
things are in line with the rest of the
evidence in other muscle groups so to me
that's how I read the data on the biceps
and triceps is
that there's not enough data to be
completely certain yet but it seems to
conform and align with the evidence on
the remaining muscle groups and
therefore that's why my rough takeaway
from the overall evidence is H this
seems to be a generalizable principle
and interestingly enough
um it's interesting that these two
muscle groups have been singled out as
being potentially not as responsive to
non muscling training because we do have
evidence in them and the evidence isn't
leaning in that direction in my
opinion so moving on to another another
claim that that often gets bandied about
um
one thing you'll you'll often encounter
is people saying that training at long
muscle links only increases muscle size
by increasing sarir in series or or
muscle length um and and that statement
is is often made with quite a bit of
confidence uh is that something that we
know like is that something that is well
established in the research or
established in the research to any
degree whatsoever yeah this is
interesting because I recently had a
discussion around this with someone and
uh the most direct data they came up
with was a study looking at LM
lengthening surgery hell yeah hell yeah
so I was just taken a bit back at how
indirect of a piece of evidence that was
and I think that kind of points at the
general situation we have here the
general situation we have here with um
ler muscle
training being more
hypotrophic as a result of addition of s
miros in series or S
Genesis we just don't know that to be
the case at all um there is some
evidence of this occurring or the
addition of S Series occurring as it
relates to passive stretching in mainly
animal models but one in humans the
picture is much Messier we don't have as
much evidence there two we have next to
no evidence of s neurogenesis Within
These studies on range of motion or
longer muscle length training and short
muscle length training and three it's
very far from being the case that we've
established this in the research as
being the mechanism of choice uh it's
just not something that we've
established I don't really know where
this came from to be honest I think it
may be the same as a passive tension as
the sole mechanism for longer muscle
length training where it seems to have
been General ized from some of the
stretch data but again it's uh it's a
stretch yeah uh I I I do think I have a
decent idea of where it comes from
actually so
I'll and and this this again kind of
gets to what we were talking about
before where like if you're trying to
establish something as like a a
mechanistic explanation of some
phenomenon you're interested in ideally
you want to observe that within the
Contex
of a study being done on the actual
phenomenon you're interested in so here
ideally you would want uh a study
comparing training at two different
muscle lengths that did assess changes
in muscle length following training um
and then look to see if changes in
muscle and and if you did observe more
total hypertrophy in the long muscle
length group see whether changes in
muscle length were like super strongly
associated with the degree of like
outperformance of long muscle length
training um and I think like a within
subject unilateral design would be ideal
for that if someone listening wants to
do that study that would be very cool um
but yeah like I so that that's how you
would want to look at it um where I
think the claim comes from is kind of
porting research from other contexts
into this context where there have been
studies where like there there is just
like a single training group maybe
compared against a control group or
whatever and the training group does do
an exercise that involves training at
long muscle links and increases in fical
length are observed in that group and so
then that is kind of like ported over to
say therefore that is the explanation
for all of these findings um which again
that's not how one would go about
establishing that it like that that is a
way to generate hypothesis that is not a
way to generate
explanations um and the other thing I
want to say about that
is like most of the most of the invivo
research that one would even use
to establish the
idea that so okay the I the idea here is
essentially that like you can increase
total muscle mass by
increasing the cross-sectional area or
thickness or or like some some sort of
like thickness measure of fibers um or
you could increase total muscle mass by
increasing the number of sarir in series
like you know you you lengthen a muscle
you expose it to a stretch stimulus
previously a muscle fiber had 550 sarir
lined up in to in from one tendon to
another and now after the stretch
intervention uh it has 550 sarir stacked
into to end so even if those sarir don't
increase in cross-sectional area now you
have 10% more muscle mass CU you added
10% more sarum like that those are kind
of two two of the ways that a muscle
could grow and so yeah that that is
essentially the idea here but then
you're listening to this and you might
be asking hey how would one
establish that sarcomerogenesis had
occurred in the first place that an
increase in muscle length uh or like an
increase in muscle mass was driven by uh
an increase in sarir in
series like most of the time uh if
you're doing research on that topic you
would use um ultrasound scans to measure
phasical length so basically like your
muscle fibers are arranged in these
little bundles called fases and you can
measure the length of those fases and
basically if a fasle of muscle mus
fibers gets 8% longer or something um it
is often then just assumed that it is 8%
longer because the muscle fibers in that
faasle have 8% more sarum in series and
that feels like a reasonable assumption
to make but based on my tone of voice I
think you see where I'm going with this
that's actually not particularly well
established um like that is often times
just a mere assumption being made um and
a group of researchers led by pinchera
and colleagues um actually published a
study uh first online in
2021 uh in print January
2022 looking at this um
so if you
so the the another assumption
underpinning that idea that an increase
in fast link scales basically one to one
with an increase in sarum and series
like an idea underpinning that is that
the resting length of sarir doesn't
change essentially at resting length you
know if a sarir is like
three uh nanometers or whatever it's
always going to be three nanometers like
it's never going to be five nanometers
um like at resting length you're going
to have similar act and meas and overlap
and so what these folks did
is they um it it was like a three-week
training intervention with with Nordic
curls like Ecentric only hamstring
training uh and the reason they chose
that is like uh Nordic curls do very
reliably increase fasal length of the
biceps for moris longe head so you know
nice nice quick easy uh training
intervention to very reliably induce the
increase in fastco link that you want to
observe and from there uh instead of
just seeing the increase in fasal length
and being like Oh yeah like this is
definitely due to an increase in sarir
in series they took biopsies of the bi
of the biceps femoris and they wanted to
see like hey how like are each of the
sarir that were looking at under the
microscope are they actually the same
length pre and post and what they
observed was that there was I think a
21% increase in fasal length and a 177%
increase in resting sarir length and so
who knows like maybe uh maybe like saram
in series increase by like 4% but like
the vast majority of the increase in
fastc length observed um you would not
need to make recourse to increases in
sarum and series to explain that finding
like it did seem to be primarily driven
by increases in sarir length um and so
yeah like even even to the extent that
there is some research finding increases
in fasal length with long muscle length
training again like not in a context
where you're like directly comparing it
to Shorter muscle length training or
full range of motion training or
whatever um but like just with with that
sort of experimental model finding an
increase in fascal length you cannot
then like strongly assume that that
increase in fasal length is directly
indicative of increases in sarir and
series cuz yeah like there are other
explanations for increases in fasal
length and to the extent that this has
been studied in humans which isn't to a
great extent like there's not a ton of
research on this topic um but like you
know when when these folks did actually
try to look into it quite recently they
found that like oh no it doesn't
actually seem like sarcomerogenesis
is the main thing driving increases in
fasal length like observe in Vivo
following a resistance training
intervention yeah man it's a remarkably
misunderstood area I think um
it's very opaque to a lot of people and
it's especially interesting when you
consider
that some people will genuinely just
take it upon themselves to try and pay
it down to this one thing but without
even fully understanding how muddled
this one thing
is um which makes yeah which makes
dissecting that take even more difficult
I think on public form
because there's a lot of assumptions
baked in mhm you know whereas if you're
looking at the applied research you're
like oh we see more hypertrophy it's
like okay this is pretty straightforward
but if you're talking about a mechanism
that has several assumptions baked into
it and you need to look at the evidence
on each of those assumptions like for
example in this case the assumption that
it is an addition of sorir uh versus
simply a lengthening of existing
sorir you know that turns into a very
tedious process uh and very difficult to
I think communicate effectively as well
yeah no I I agree I agree Ju Just to
just to like very briefly complain about
this for a second like it it does
frustrate me a little bit um and like
I'm I'm sure I've made this exact point
or something very similar to it on the
podcast before but like just the
difference between
like trying to approach expert or like
like trying to approach research um like
kind of soberly and
rationally um and and being very careful
about the types of claims you can make
from it and often times like when you're
dealing with a phenomenon that is
observed and well established as a
phenomenon but the cause of the of the
phenomenon isn't well established just
being willing to say like hey like we
don't know why this occurs here are some
potential explanations but like really
we just need more research to find out
like that I think to a lot of people and
probably even most people um comes
across
as
[Music]
um it it gives a presentation of less
expertise
than if you are willing to say like hey
here's something we observed and like we
know why this is and uh then like the
proposed mechanism you throw out there
you state it with confidence and it
sounds sufficiently plausible because
like I I mean in so you know if someone
listening isn't going to spend a couple
weeks digging into all of the research
on this topic which like no one is like
why would they people have other things
going on and like uh would would I
rather just in a vacuum sit down and
watch sports for 3 hours at night or
like dig into Pub Med for 3 hours it
depends on the night but like often
times you know I'm I'm not going to be
doing that for fun and so like most of
the time the only folks who have really
time to get into this stuff are folks
for whom it is their job and like even
if you're a trainer or coach like you
don't need to know like
the intricacies of the research on a
particular topic like like you just
don't it's not like that relevant to you
and so you know in if if if you don't
have like the time or quite frankly the
ability to like dig into a lot of this
stuff yourself and in a vacuum you're
presented with two people and they
make not drastically dissimilar claims
about something and one of them say and
one of them says
and I can explain why we observe this
and the other one says I can't explain
why we observe this in a vacuum the one
who who confidently claims to have an
explanation sounds like they know more
about the topic and so I don't know it
it I I feel like just human psychology
incentivizes people to get way out over
their skis in a way that's like not
scientifically justifiable but
like it it works you know and that
it it bugs me it gets under my skin yeah
man and not to do the good old appeal to
Authority here but I think if
you read a few studies in the area right
and listen to the takes of a few
researchers in the area and they don't
mirror what someone is claiming is
definitely the
case some skepticism is in order I think
as to those claims right and with the
range of motion data if you read the
discussions of virtually any longer
versus shorter muscle L paper in the
past like 5 10 years very few of any
have like ever said with any certainty
that hey it must be the fast calls baby
you know like it's yeah it's just not
that clear so I think that's the kind of
litus test I would Advocate it for if
you're uh not willing to spend three
weeks in an area but you do want to get
an idea of okay do we really know
this
so like one one of
the kind of like secondary claims made
off of the idea that the hypertrophy
advantages of training at long muscle
links are all simply due to increases in
sarir and series uh kind of a follow-up
idea to that is the idea that like hey
um you know you can't you can't just
like infinitely increase muscle length
like eventually we'd just be walking
around with floppy spaghetti noodles and
like that's not like floppy spaghetti
noodles as muscles like that's obviously
not going to happen so at some point
increases in muscle length are going to
run out um and probably relatively
quickly
therefore um even if long muscle length
training causes more hypertrophy in the
short term that should be a relatively
limited phenomenon so basically if like
we might observe long muscle length
training causing more growth over 3
months but like maybe after 3 months or
after 6 months longer and shorter muscle
length training would cause like
basically identical ongoing muscle
growth because you're not still uh see
seeing the increase in muscle length
from the long muscle length training
um and so I'm I'm wondering what you
think about that idea more broadly not
just in the context of increases in
muscle length but just the idea that
like maybe this is kind of a short-term
phenomenon
maybe um you know maybe it's like kind
of like a novelty effect uh or kind of
like you know functional differences in
training experience like you you like
even in the studies where the folks do
have some training experience maybe
folks do habitually train through a
somewhat shorter range of motion and so
yeah if you have them train in a longer
through a longer range of motion it
causes more growth but just because like
it's kind of a new stressor they're
being exposed to so
you know kind kind of the the broad idea
is like maybe this maybe even if long
muscle length training does cause more
growth it it would be a short-term thing
and wouldn't extend to like a threeyear
fiveyear Time Horizon what what do you
think about that again just on a gut
level because there's not fiveyear
studies on this but like do do you think
do you think that the results that we
see over 3 or 4 months would generalize
over 3 or four years great question
truth is we don't know um as you
mentioned we don't have those 5year
studies
yet until we do we couldn't really say
for sure and I think this is where it's
tempting to have a mechanism to pin
everything onto because then with an
understanding of that mechanism we would
have a better idea the other issue with
the existing data is that we don't have
studies in particularly trained people
and that's actually Something That We're
trying to address with a study that's
coming up that is using participants
that have train for at least 3 years but
in general those are weaknesses of the
area
personally until we have a compelling
reason to believe that this doesn't
extend into time and by the way I think
novelty novelty is kind of a buzz word
nowadays and a platitude where people
often use the web Novelties to explain
way okay higher volumes cause more
growth but it's novelty and then after 2
weeks you don't see any additional
growth anymore what have you right like
novelty is this thing where it's like
you get those gains once and you don't
get them back like you don't get them
again afterwards
um novelty to my knowledge isn't
actually all that well evidenced when it
comes to different things in lifting and
hypertrophy like for example there was
one study that compared a constant uh
resistance training program to one where
you constantly change things up like
different de Center creations different
uh exercise patterns the the 2019 damus
study that is correct hey look at you
knowing knowing it instantly um now it's
not a perfect study of novelty but in
general the idea that novelty for
example in terms of volume there was a
recent review paper on does your
previous volume impact your hypertrophy
response to new volumes right like for
example if you did super high volumes
before does going into lower volumes
impact how much approach you see or does
doing super low volume before impact how
much appro you see if now you were to
increase volume so essentially a novel
amount of volume and it just doesn't
really seem to be the case that much so
novelty in general I think is at this
point not a super
compelling reason to explain a way an
idea and I think that applies to Long
mus L research as well now it's not an
area where you have a ton of confidence
or a ton of data but it does not until
we have a solid reason to think it
doesn't appear longlasting
I think it's a reasonable thing to say
okay in the course of 12 weeks or so
this seems to lead to more hypertrophy
so it's probably something that on net
balance is worth trying even for a long
term I think that's fair one of one of
my um should I call it a non-scientific
belief I don't want to trivialize it too
much ah [__] it I will whatever one of
one of my kind of non-scientific beliefs
but I don't think anti-scientific
beliefs is is I do I do think there's
something to novelty personally
um and I kind of don't think that
the I don't I don't think that there are
ideal studies to test that hypothesis
yet
um but yeah I don't know I don't know
that's that's another conversation for
another day I don't I don't think that
it's uh I I don't I don't think the dham
study is like that strong of evidence
against it like it it it certainly lend
some degree of evidence against the idea
that novelty is important but I think I
think that to the extent that it would
matter it would be within the context of
habituation and so kind of like changing
the stressor every session wouldn't
necessarily do much for you but like for
instance if like a a kind of like simple
like
operationalized version of this that
someone could test if they wanted to
would be in
not really simple this this would be a
huge pain in the ass to do cuz like it's
going to have to be a long study either
way which is very
unfortunate um but like I would love to
see a paper that just like does
alternating blocks of moderate and low
intensity training where you do like 6
to8 weeks of training at 30 40% 1 RM 6
to8 weeks of training at 70 80% 1 RM uh
and just kind of like alternate versus
one group that only trains at 30 40 and
one group that only trains at 7080 um
and kind of see if over a year You
observe more growth and like a more
consistent trajectory of growth in the
people changing out the stimuli like you
know it it takes you a few weeks to like
habituate to a stimulus but by the time
you've done that like by the time you've
habituated to the lower intensity stuff
you're like considerably less habituated
to the like moderate intensity stuff and
kind of like but the the s Ulus of those
two things in isolation should more or
less be similar so I don't know I I
would like to see a study like that I I
do think I do think that the group
alternating would ultimately grow more
over the course of the year than either
of the groups that only stuck with one
stimulus the whole time but I can't
claim to know that for certain but yeah
that's that's also too far off the
beaten path I don't think we should go
too far down that rabbit hole but yeah I
I agree with you um about the the long
muscle length training I think that I I
do think that the idea of novelty when
it's invoked is sometimes done so in
like a bit of a bad faith way where any
research finding you like and agree with
uh is robust and durable and is not due
to novelty and will extend infinitely
into the future and any research finding
that you don't agree with is purely due
to novelty and was only observed due to
the shortterm nature of the study and
wouldn't extend into the future
and yeah I mean if if we're being fair
when evaluating research we should not
apply that critique exclusively to
studies that don't fit our priors but I
also I I I find it difficult to be
Grudge people doing that cuz like uh
well okay here's an example uh there was
a
paper um oh man I'm blanking on the
researcher's name um I believe it was I
believe it was out of Norway but it was
uh it was a study looking at Blood Flow
Restriction Training and the squat in
powerlifters and basically finding like
really
really um like quite
substantial preferential type one muscle
fiber growth over the course of like six
weeks uh or something like that and I
don't know like I I look at that and I'm
like yeah if if a powerlifter does like
supplemental Blood Flow Restriction
Training for their quads for a year I
don't think you would continue see like
a four-fold advantage in type 1 fiber
growth over the course of a year like I
and I kind of think that the
preferential type 1 fiber growth
observed in that study was probably due
to novelty um so like I I get I get it
you know like I I do the same thing but
I think it is a tendency to try to
notice in yourself and try try to guard
again so you can evaluate stuff as
fairly as possible for sure what I would
say a few things one with regards to the
greater type one Hy pery in that study
to what extent do you think we can
distinguish between something having a
component of novelty and the person
simply being less trained and do we
think those are even distinct things
because you know you could say oh uh new
lifters grow more because of novelty
they've never lifted before it's just
Noel to them or we could say they're new
to lifting and thus they have a faster
rate of muscle growth right which do you
think it is
um I think it's both and I think it's
both and I think that um to probably
like massively oversimplify it I do
think that by and large like in not like
a linear way but with a generally
positive relationship you tend to see
larger physiological responses to larger
stressors and I think the idea of larger
stressor should be oper operationalized
within the context of Prior exposure to
a specific stressor and general versions
of the same
stressor and so I think one of the
reasons that you see more hypertrophy in
untrained lifters is that they are like
they they don't have like prior
exposures to stimuli that are similar to
resistance training and so like for any
given external training stimulus the
internal training stimulus is larger
just because like there's a bigger
mismatch between like PRI prior exposure
and current
exposure um and so I do think that
like and like I don't think that's like
the full explanation for it like I I
also think that like you have some
surface area to volume constraints and
like myonuclear domain constraints that
may influence like potential rates of
muscle growth and you know those are
starting relatively low with untrained
lifters and they would be starting
relatively high with um with trained
lifters who are just like changing
training variables but like just the and
so like I think that that is like the
primary explanation for why untrained
lifters grow faster um but I I do think
a lot of it does have to do with like
the magnitude of the stimulus itself
kind of per se and so you know an
untrained lifter being exposed to
training for the first time would be a
much
larger um like change in exposure and
therefore like a much larger like
relative internal stimulus then a
trained lifter who's been only doing
sets of eight
for um you know 16 weeks shifting and
only doing sets of 30 like that's you
know going from sets of eight to sets of
30 is not as big of a change as going
from no training at all to now you're
doing some form of training but I do
think it's enough of a different
stimulus that um it would it would in
general kind of be a larger internal
stressor just because you haven't
habituated to it over the course of like
you you've habituated to a somewhat Sim
similar stimulus but there are
differences in those stimuli that you
would not have habituated to over you
know frequen prior exposures and so I do
think it would be kind of like
conceptually similar to a person
training for the first time um but like
with a tremendous difference in degree
effectively that's that that's kind of
how I think about it sure I mean I think
it makes a lot of sense I think
novelty it's going to be a difficult
thing to study regardless and existing
studies haven't done a super good job of
addressing it um since you mentioned
kind of
like differences in dose of training or
stressor of training or the amount of
stress essentially dictating to an
extent the uh response I thought I'd
quickly bring up we mentioned mechanisms
with lower muscle length training but I
think peeling it back one layer we can
kind of talk about different layers of
mechanisms from something being a bit
more practical and applied to being a
bit more actual okay molecularly what's
going on here physiologically was um
with regards to the mechanism with
longer muscling training I think there
are two things happening that are
relatively clear and that do likely
contribute to hypertrophy the first one
doesn't necessarily and that's simply
that it seems like spending more time at
on average longer muscle lengths is to
some extent in some capacity a mediator
right it's not ultimately what's causing
the muscle growth itself but the thing
that unites these different areas of
literature right from partials at
different muscle lengths to for range of
motion versus long muscle length
partials to isometric different muscle
lengths is ultimately you're spending
more time at on average longer muscle
lengths now when you're doing a four
range of motion you will always be also
hit getting the longest muscle length
possible but you'll be spending some
proportion of each set in at shorter
muscle lengths and so if we see that
actually partial range of motion can
lead to more muscle growth than a 4
range of motion even though a 4 range of
motion always includes the longest
possible muscle length it likely doesn't
have to do with simply existing or
targeting that longest muscle length but
more so with spending on average more
time at longer muscle lengths that Mak
sense it's not about simply achieving
the longest muscle length possible it's
more so about simply spending more time
at a reasonably long muscle length on
average so that's one thing the second
thing is when you're using a length and
partial approach you will generally if
you're just going to failure defined as
inability to perform another
repetition with a length and partial
approach you will generally end the set
past quote unquote full range of motion
failure right so you can probably do a
length and partial for lot of exercises
past the point at which you could do
another full range of motion rep and so
if we're just comparing length and
partials but ending the set when you
can't do another partial to a full range
of motion ending the set when you can't
do another full rep when you're doing a
length and partial you're going closer
to quotequote True failure or you're
going past full range of motion failure
and so I think some of the additional
hypertrophy we might see using length
and partials could simply be due to the
fact that you going past failure and
generally we do see a relationship
between going closer to failure and more
hypertrophy so I think that might be
what's happening here and I think it's
one of the
more uh substantiated things that might
be a play yeah that's that that is an
interesting point that I that I Hann and
herd brought up before just the kind
kind of proximity to failure deal um h i
i i wonder I wonder how you would test
that there is a way to do it you would
just do lengthen partial in one group
versus full range of motion the other
but not ending the set at full range of
motion failure But continuing to do
partials until you can't get a partial
with the same range of motion as the
other group and that's actually a study
that I want to do ASAP um potentially in
New York with Brad shenfeld that would
be good because that would address that
question and also most people don't like
doing L partials anyways they prefer
doing like full range of motion and just
busting out some length and partials at
the end when they feel like they're
getting close to failure and fatigued so
it's a study we want to do yeah yeah
that that would be really cool to see I
think yeah I so h i do Wonder like the
the idea of like time
spent at long muscle links I
do I'm not totally sure I agree with you
on that but I am persuadable I suppose
so uh thought experiment let's say
you're doing ah let's just do bicep
curls cuz it's easy
and let's say you're
doing uh either full range of motion
reps you know full elbow extension to
full elbow flexion versus long muscle
length bicep curls just at the bottom of
the range of
motion uh like the the bottom half
specifically one
half
so
if rates of fatigue are similar and and
like let's let's just make this easy and
say that you're performing reps at a pre
predescribed uh angular velocity for
elbow flexion uh like Ju Just just we're
we're in the realm of thought
experiments now but like actually not
like fully you could you could totally
do the study on a isokinetic dynamometer
it' be cool to see um in fact this isn't
that similar to the soo study except
that was just two different partial
ranges of motion I think that was
isokinetic whatever doesn't matter but
yeah so uh um you're you're
standardizing angular velocity for elbow
flexion as well and and let's let's just
also say that you're like prescribing um
you know you're you're you're doing like
three sets of 10 at 70% 1 RM uh well
since since it's isokinetic 70% of MVC
like we're F fully AB abstracting this
[__] it seems like the total time spent
at long muscle links would be the same
um and I don't think that it would like
change that much when you go back to
normal training cuz like you know if if
like a rep is taking 2 seconds with the
full range of motion because you also
have the top half and it's taking 1
second with the lengthen partials um and
you're doing 10 reps like you're
spending 10 seconds in length and
partial land uh in both setups but
like uh like I I guess in the real world
you would still probably wind up doing
more reps before you fatigued with with
the lengthen partials but I I wonder how
distinct that is from the other point of
just being able to go past the point of
failure cuz in a what would be happening
there is like if you're if you weren't
standardizing reps per set you would
incur some fatigue during the top half
of each rep and that would reduce the
number of lengthen partials you could do
but
like uh yeah I don't know I don't know
I'll I'll I'll have to Stew on that I'm
sorry that you you can respond to
anything in there that I just said but I
think I may have just been talking to
myself and working through something
without a clear
[Laughter]
question no I get where you're coming
from and to be clear by more time spent
at lower muscle lengths I didn't I more
so used it as short hand for more time
and or U Force produced just a
combination of those things right um I
do think that is distinct from Simply
going closer to failure and the reason
why I specify that is because to my
knowledge the effects of going two
failure versus say five reps in reserve
there doesn't really seem to be an
effect on Regional hypertrophy And yet
when we're looking at the range of
motion data we do see an effect on
Regional hypertrophy of for example
length and partials for spange motion
and so forth so at the very least it
doesn't seem to be the only thing I play
and that's why I'm not just saying like
yep it's probably just cuz you're
pushing extra hard baby you know it's
probably something more to it than that
yeah yeah that that makes sense that
makes sense H whatever [__] it let's go
down this Rabbit Hole I wonder what's
your take on so-called metabolic stress
being at all relevant for hypertrophy
outcomes cuz I I kind
one of the studies that you talked about
that I'm
not totally sure that I
agree with your take on um is the is the
goo tricep study where you have one
group training 0 to 120° of elbow
flexion one group just going 45 to 90 um
like I I do acknowledge that the average
degree of elbow flexion being trained at
is greater in the partial group than the
full range of motion group but you do
you do also have those 30 extra degrees
at the bottom of the range of motion
that you're going through with the full
range of range of motion group that that
you weren't with the partials like the
maximal degree of elbow flexion the
maximal muscle links being trained were
certainly greater with the full range of
motion group than the partial um and
that study did observe considerably more
triceps growth with the kind of like
middle of the range of motion partials
than full range of motion so like I
could see how that could credibly be
used to argue against muscle links being
a driver there like uh and it's kind of
a it it does beg the question of like
whether maximum muscle length or average
muscle length matters more um but yeah
like I I I don't know for me personally
I wouldn't look at that and like chalk
it up is one in the in the long muscle
length column um or not like it's it's
not obvious to me that that is the way
that that should be kind of accounted
for but um I do think that the
interesting thing about it was that in
the partial range of motion training
group the area under the uh the the
oxyhemoglobin desaturation curve was was
associated with the hypertrophy observed
and it does also strike me
that for not every exercise but for most
exercises partials at long muscle length
would keep the muscle under tension um
which it it hasn't always done so in the
research so like with the Pedrosa quad
studies like it was a dynamometer there
was like a mechanical stop at the bottom
so like the people's quads could have
been like slightly not underload at the
bottom of each rep but like you know if
you were doing squats for instance just
in the hole and Midway up like your
quads are underload the whole time um
and so like I do wonder the degree to
which that's relevant because when you
lock out a rep with a lot of exercises
you can like relax some of your muscles
and when you relax muscles you can get
more blood flow into the muscle like uh
and clear more metabolites out like the
um the circumferential expansion of the
muscle like during intense
contractions uh for depending on muscle
size and muscle and what veins and
arteries are going in and out does often
like cut off Venus blood flow relatively
quickly and can even like significantly
restrict arterial blood flow as well in
some
contexts and so like there there would
be like metabolic
differences
between long length partials and full
range motion training in a lot of
contexts and so like I do wonder the
extent to which that is relevant for the
results being observed particularly with
the uh the goo study in mind since that
was something it it was like kind of
looking at as well so I'm I'm curious
about your take on that so I think with
the goto study uh the fact that they
measured oxygenation and lactate was
interesting now to my knowledge and like
definitely correct me instantly if I'm
wrong here um the role of hypoxia and by
hypoxia I mean specifically like the
oxygenation of a muscle as it directly
relates to causing
hypertrophy doesn't seem too promising
currently or am I completely off base
here um hm how how are you using the
word
cause um in that it independently of
other
mechanisms uh leads to hypertrophy uh I
think that's the case but in this
instance it's not independent of other
mechanisms because it's in the context
of of a resistance training stimulus
where there are a bunch of other things
going on sure so you mean that that
would then lead to differences for
example in like El lactic accumulation
and therefore that could lead to more
hypertrophy or what do you mean by this
exactly this is this is just like one of
my hot takes I I do think people have
kind of like closed the door on um like
metabolic stimuli as a contributor to
hypertrophy a little bit too
quickly um I think that
essentially we have gotten very hung up
on like
initiators of hypertrophy signaling and
kind of like independent direct causes
but effectively like hypertrophy is
quite complicated like essentially you
you have an initial stimulus that kind
of like is is censed by generally by
some structure and like that's that's
another thing we're not even like
totally sure what kicks off the
hypertrophy signaling Cascade like
there's hypotheses that like it is
probably some sort of like camir
Associated protein like focal adhesion
kyes but I don't think that's like fully
proven yet but essentially like some
mechanosensitive structure senses
hypertrophy and it you know probably
phosphorites some Downstream proteins
and then you know you have like four or
five steps and then eventually that's
like integrated in the mtor complex and
then you have another like five or six
steps ultimately resulting in increases
in myogenic regulatory factors that
influence gene expression that codes for
various proteins a lot of them
contractile proteins and then you know
that has to go to
the ribosomes to be translated and so
then you have like potential constraints
on like translational capacity and like
event you know eventually you wind up
with more contractile proteins than you
had before but like it's not as simple
as tension occurs it is SED muscle
growth happens bada bing bada boom like
it's I mean it's like a [__] 20-step
process and that that's just like one of
the canonical signaling Cascades cuz
like they're they're like non-im Tor
mediated hyper fre signaling Cascades as
well and
so um it does seem like based on our
current understanding it does seem like
the primary or perhaps even sole
initiator of that Cascade is probably
mechanical tension but that certainly
doesn't come anywhere close to meaning
that the um you know that that's like
the only thing that's relevant cuz like
things could influence other other parts
of that c Cascade um like just as one
example like getting sick causes like
pretty significant ramp UPS in mour
activation and so like if if it really
was that simple Like A to B to C you
could just say hey like you know
eventually those tension stimuli get
integrated at mtor and then Downstream
of that hypertrophy occurs
but like you know if it were that simple
just kind of logical flow you could say
well as long as we get the ramp up in
mtor who cares how it's initiated
because that will necessarily lead to
all of the downstream effects that we
also see following resistance training
so like just [__] get sick and get
huge you know but like obviously that
doesn't happen because like so many
other things about the intramuscular
environment are different during
resistance training than when you're
sick that like there are things that
modulate all of the steps of that
process Downstream from mtor activation
leading to very different phenotypic
responses to lifting versus being sick
um and so like I don't know
I it
seems likely to me that some type of
like metabolic
stimulus probably like influences some
of the steps of that process or even
like multiple metabolic stimuli could
influence like multiple different steps
of that process and I personally would
be quite surprised if they didn't
because if it were if it were just all
about tension we could go like a step
more basic and just say like Hey we're
we're kind of wasting time by lifting
weights in a normal way cuz like
ultimately the amount like the amount we
can do is constrained by our ability to
produce Force
concentrically like you can produce way
more Force well not way more but like
you can produce more Force isometrically
than cons Cally so like you know [__]
all of this like lifting weight stuff
just like chain a bar to the floor move
your body around the bar and just do
isometrics like that will put more
tension on the muscle than anything else
well not than anything cuz you can get
more Ecentric as well but like you know
it'll be more than you can get from
conventional training and like why why
even go to the gym just chain a bar to
the floor and you've got like the
perfect training Implement for more
hypertrophy than you could achieve any
other way
um but like no one does that and I don't
think anyone like actually believes that
that would lead to more not even as much
growth much less more growth um which
like if you could fully reduce it to
tension that would be not just like a
hypothesis you would generate but like a
logical conclusion that you could like
very confidently arrive at um but like a
key difference there's like the there
there are a lot of like meta olic
effects of dynamic resistance training
that either don't occur or don't occur
to nearly the same degree as with
isometric training and so like uh I
don't know I think I think like I think
like some of that stuff is relevant and
I'm not going to claim that I know
precisely mechanistically kind of like
where it slots in and what steps of
those canonical hypertrophy signaling
Cascades that it modulates but I I
personally would be quite surprised if
it didn't have some
influence yeah it's interesting I mean
my main takeaway from all that was just
my to-do list now has buy barbell and
buy chains on it that's the main thing
really main takeaway um what I was going
to say though is it's interesting to
reflect on and I've read for example one
paper on stimuli sensors that initiate
skeletal hypertrophy right and even
reading that you as a review paper you
kind of understand okay we we don't
fully understand the mechanisms or all
the mechanisms and how they interact for
hypertrophy let alone specifically when
it comes to longer muscle length
training versus shorter muscle length
training and so like it's entirely
plausible that some aspect of metab
metabolite stress or what have you is
involved in longer muscle length
training and while least to more
hypertrophy as you mentioned if by doing
length imp partials you're staying under
quotequote more constant tension for
example that might be playing a role at
this point we just don't really know and
I think ultimately that's what we have
to come to terms with until we get more
evidence and as you said more evidence
within the same studies that are
actually looking at hypertrophy versus
like different samples and that's part
of the tricky component is that if
you're doing one of these applied
studies usually that's partly because
you don't have these means to measure
mechanistic stuff as easily so MH kind
of a cash 22 and I mean ideally you
would want to be able to establish a lot
of this stuff in in Vivo like in living
organisms and like in that context
unless you're really confident
generalizing research from transgenic
mice like it is difficult to
disambiguate a lot of this stuff cuz you
know for for instance like proximity to
failure generally that's going to
increase motor unit Recruitment and like
per fiber tension for the fibers that
are still recruited at the point of
failure as you approach failure and so
you could could look at some of the
stuff saying like ah we might be seeing
more growth when people train closer to
failure and say that like ooh that's all
about tension but uh it's difficult to
establish that because you can't
disentangle it from everything else
because in in effect you're you are just
dealing with a larger Global stimulus
like if you go to failure versus
stopping us at to rep shy of failure
yeah tension goes up but like the
metabolic stress is going to go up as
well like um your probably going to get
more muscle damage and like post
exercise inflammation which can like
modulate hypertrophy responses as well
so like does it all reduce to
tension uh who knows maybe it does but
like uh like in in general like it's
it's difficult to like
increase the intensity of some proposed
mechanistic stimuli or like modulator
without also affecting others in living
organisms and so yeah I don't know this
this stuff is is is very challenging to
study no for sure it's it's immensely
difficult to measure any of the stimula
isolation um I know that's a big area of
concern for example when measuring the
impact of certain metabolites on
hypertrophy it's difficult especially in
Vivo um but yeah hopefully one day we
have better understanding of the
mechanisms as it relates to both
hypertrophy but also more specifically
range of motion
I I just have a couple more questions
for you real quick um so I'm
wondering what what do you make of
studies where and talking about the uh
the goo tricep study a little bit
previously was was a bit of a setup for
this question um what what do you think
about studies where the group training
at the longest maximal muscle length
doesn't achieve more hypertrophy than a
group it's being compared against um so
for example there was a a squat study um
by Kubo and colleagues where one group
squatted from0 to 120° of knee flexion
full range of motion the other group
squatted 0 to 90° and quad growth was
pretty similar in that study um versus
like most of the other quad research
like 90° of knee flexion is like the
long muscle length group and it's being
compared against something considerably
shorter than that so you know it seems
like less than 90 you're seeing
decreases in growth but like you know
that study at least didn't observe
differences between 90 and 120 the goo
tricep study you know with uh with mayo
and arguably
stasak it seems like you're seeing
increases in tricep growth going past 90
degrees of elbow flexion but um
with with the goo
study like going up to 120 degrees
didn't outperform going up to 90° and so
it it you know it's it's not all
unanimous so I'm
wondering what you think explains that
it could it just be kind of like oneoff
studies that you know it's just like
sampling variability or just like some
some [__] that like wouldn't necessarily
generalize or do you think like you know
maybe
um you know you need to get to Long
muscle lengths but past a certain point
further increases in muscle length being
trained don't actually cause like
continued increases in hypertrophy like
there there are a lot of potential
explanations but like what where where
do you think that leans so I think with
the goo study specifically as I said I
think the par Ranger motion group was
actually treating at longer muscle
lengths on average right like yes the
four Ranger motion group actually went
deeper on each rep but they also spent
proportionately a lot more time at Short
muscle lengths
so it may be more so related to again
average position average muscle length
being achieved during the set versus
just achieving the longest muscle length
possible at some point during that set
if that makes sense um in general I do
think
that it's not entirely implausible that
there is such a thing as like long
enough right where just because you've
achieved a long enough muscle length
you're sort of you've capped off that
benefit um equally when it comes for
example to the Kubo study and the quads
where you're comparing 120° to 90° and
you didn't see more hypertrophy when
going to 120 degre of knee
flexion to me I'm of two minds on the
one hand it makes sense that there's a
threshold and part of me want to say y
well it seems like with K study 90° of
KNE flection might be all you need to
maximize quad
hypertrophy however on the other hand
we're talking about a comparison of 30°
of knee flexion which depending on how
large of an effect we're expecting here
in terms of the impact of muscle length
on hypertrophy may just not be a big
enough difference to see a difference in
hypertrophy as a result right that's one
explanation additionally kind of on the
back of that is we do have studies where
we're comparing long muscle length
training to longer muscle length
training so for example the study by
casano and colleagues where they
compared calf razes with the knees fully
extended um so they were essentially
doing calf raises on leg press and they
compared doing either 4ange motion calf
raises just doing the top half so
shorten partials or just doing the
bottom half or lengthen partials and
they measured gastro hypertrophy now
because the knees are extended and the
gastro is a KNE flexor in any of the
three groups the gas Rock should have
been reasonably lengthened already
however we're talking about reasonably
lengthened in the case of the for of
motion and maybe even the short and
partial group versus very or maximally
lengthened for the um lengthen partial
group in this study and indeed in the
Cavs they did see more hypertrophy when
doing lengthened partials as opposed to
Just 4 in of motion which was still
quite lengthened right because the knes
were fully extended for the Gast Ro so
on the whole I'm tempted to think that
there is some muchat of a do response
relationship here and it's not just a
cap off where like okay you've hit um
80% of possible muscle length you've got
all the hypy congratulations I think it
may be somewhat more of with those
response in the same fashion as you see
for
um volume or relative intensity where
the more volume you do or the closer to
failure you train all else being equal
probably the more H perch you see I
suspect it may be the same for muscle
length but to be perfectly Frank we just
don't have the number of studies
required that have investigated maximum
muscle lengths so at this point I think
it's all a bit of a shot in the dark um
it could be that you're somewhat correct
in your assumption that hey maybe we
don't need maximum muscle links maybe
just long enough is good enough or it
could be that there is a do response but
it's difficult to pick up on that when
we have like two or three studies
actually looking at that and generally
some of these comparisons are relatively
modest in the difference in muscle
length achieved yeah I think I think
that's fair um
primarily so you can so you can respond
to the haters out there a a a criticism
of you that I have seen and also of of
people who I think follow you and parrot
your stuff not the best um is that you
you and you and folks that follow you
are maybe like a bit too gung-ho about
lengthened partials and that uh you
think that that full range emotion is
over and
you're you're you're kind of like
sending people
down uh a rabbit Trail instead of like
you know sticking to the basics that
that there's like excessive promotion of
lengthened partials giving giving people
the the idea that like they should only
do lengthen partials and like issue you
know standard standard bread and butter
training so uh the the the floor is
yours uh respond to that do do you think
people should only do lengthen partials
if they're trying to get as big as
possible or do you do you maybe still do
some normal training
yourself it's funny because I feel like
you're pitching this question up for me
to answer that I still do some noral
training but I actually
don't um so for the past year or so I've
been doing exclusive length partials and
that is uh well with the exception of
the occasional squat bench or deadlift
or overhead press with full Ranger
motion for strength but I'm talking not
5% of my training has been just length
partials now I think
the the big issue here arises when
people don't realize okay this person
saying this works or this probably works
and saying okay so they're saying this
is going to revolutionize your gains or
your hypertrophy with length and
partials we're again talking about a 5
or 10% difference in hopy that's not
even measurable by most people standards
in their own physique like if they look
their own physique week to week month to
month and they switch to length and
partials for some exercises they're
probably not going even notice
right I think the other thing is
whenever we make generalizations from
the evidence to your own training we
have to make some leaps of Faith right
turns out you're not exactly the
population we were studying turns out
you're not just doing school Crushers in
your training you're also doing other
exercises there's a lot of leaps of
faith in there but I think that in
general at this stage what I can say
reasonably confidently is that you don't
want well very confidently actually is
that you don't want to miss the lengthen
position in your training if you're
going to maximize
hopy do I think that you need to be
doing only length and partials to
maximize hypertrophy I don't know yet I
just we haven't looked at that right I
think based on the evidence and the
consistency of the evidence that we
have look there's been no study that's
found better how appr with 4 in Motion
versus like partials and so I'd be hard
pressed to say that I think that someone
doing more length and partials rather
than less is going to be missing out on
hypertrophy like that that would be a
very difficult claim to substantiate at
this
point um I do think that a lot of people
are just attached to whatever range of
motion has been prevailing and it's
worth remembering that hey for range of
motion wasn't always the uh hot
commodity you know like until a few
years ago I think personally most people
didn't pay attention to range of motion
that much and then full range of motion
became kind of the consensus within
evidence-based Fitness at least and then
all of a sudden it was all about
that I don't think
that it's always been the case that
everyone's tried to maximize range of
motion and in fact if you walk to the
gym now you'll see that plenty of people
aren't doing a full range motion so
personally that's kind of my stance on
things I think that if you want to
maximize hypertrophy you probably want
to include some length partials there's
a chance that you'd optimize your
hypertrophy with only LED partials
there's a good chance you won't either I
don't really know no one really knows I
based on the evidence and there being no
studies finding more hypertrophy with
forer motion I personally on the side of
it's probably a neutral to positive
effect of doing only length and partials
I I struggled to think of a case where
you'd see a negative effect um it's
possible but we simply haven't looked at
it and so that's kind of my my whole STS
on thing yeah H you know I I think I
think this is probably one of those
other things things where you know if if
there if there was an effect you're
probably not going to to be able to like
reliably observe it in yourself but like
I don't know get getting into the idea
of like Regional hypertrophy there is
the um there is the the stasak tricep
study where it did appear that um well I
mean that that was another partial range
of motion but like it did seem like
short muscle length training did
maybe cause more growth in proximal
regions of the muscle so like
I I I would I would not be surprised at
all if exclusively doing lengthened
partials uh led to like say reliably
more distal growth than full range of
motion and maybe like middle of the
muscle it's like kind of similar but
like I wouldn't be surprised if in some
muscles only doing lengthen partials
potentially like compromised proximal
hypertrophy a little bit but again like
if Global hypertrophy winds up being
similar like who's who's really looking
at their quads and being like ah damn
like you know my my vastest lateralis
could be 5 millimeters thicker uh at the
20% femur length site than it would have
been otherwise so yeah I don't know I
don't know that's that's kind of my take
on it I I get that but for what it's
worth I think that the Stasi proximal
data is actually in contrast to the
proximal data from other studies where
they actually even in proximal sites
find more hypertrophy with lengthen work
so I wouldn't the takeaway here wouldn't
be that hey uh you might be missing yeah
that's that's that's why that's why I
said for some muscle groups yeah but it
may not even be some muscle groups it
may just be variants in my view like it
may not be that triceps are particularly
prone to more distal growth but not
proximal with length and training but
when you look at the data overall I
think
it may be more neutral for more distal
sites and more positive of the
difference for more sorry for more
proximal sites and more of a positive
difference in favor of length and
training for more distal sites but I I
don't think that there is evidence
support the idea that overall you'll see
more proximal growth doing shorten
training it may be the same but I I just
don't think the evidence overall um is
strongly in favor of that claim no I I
feel you I feel you yeah I I don't I
don't necessarily disagree with that I I
was just trying to throw throw out a
Counterpoint that someone could make
from the research I I don't so you're
extremely well read by the way um that's
a Counterpoint I've heard made but never
an actual reference to any findings so
it's interesting to see someone who
actually read the studies I do what I
can uh yeah reading reading this stuff
used to uh literally be most of my job
so I'll I'll admit uh some of the
references you've made like I I haven't
read uh casano yet um I know you you and
Pac are both coming back on soon to talk
about the like really high volume inis
study um I haven't read it yet so I I am
I am starting to get like a little
behind on some stuff but it's it's it's
still recent enough that I read
everything that I do I do still know
most references from like early this
year and before for sure well by the
time this is coming out early last year
and
before okay so my my last kind of
prepared question here is um if someone
is interested in in getting more into or
experimenting with long muscle length
training um how how could they get into
it like kind of what what would be the
baby steps that someone could take if
they they wanted to just like ease into
more long muscle length training uh or
what's kind of like the the maximalist
application that someone could take if
they just want to dive in you know head
first sure so I think there are a few
categories of things you can do to shift
your training towards being more
lengthened biased quote unquote or
longer muscle length
biased one would be the very
straightforward thing of just do length
and partials so whatever exercise you
were doing
just take those same exercises but
instead of doing a full range of motion
do length and partials I think this
might be best suited to exercises where
there's usually very little challenge in
those positions and I think this is an
area of research where we haven't even
touched on this in the podcast very much
but there might be a difference between
an exercise simply putting you at long
muscle lengths like putting the target
muscle group into a stretch position
versus also having a resistance
challenge there quote unquote so needing
to overcome a certain amount of
resistance in that position needing to
produce certain amount of active
tension um so I think simply switching
to lengthen partials might be best
reserved for muscle groups where you
otherwise don't get much tension in
those lengthen positions so for example
for most back exercises for most side
out exercises for most bicep exercises
you don't typically have a huge amount
of resistance presented at L mus lengths
and so if you were to Omit those more
shortened positions all of a sudden
you'd probably be able to use more
weight and also make that lengthen
position more challenging as a result so
that's one recommendation but in general
length and partials are actually the
thing that's been researched and so it
might be the most straightforward way of
applying this stuff you know the highest
likelihood of actually translating from
the research because it's actually what
we studied it's very straightforward to
use it kind of equalizes I think a lot
of exercises where certain exercises
might not have a great resistance curve
in light of This research but if you do
like par and for example you know you
usually fail at a shorten position or a
lockout all of a sudden you're still
getting a good amount of length and
stimulus by just omitting that part of
the range
motion so that's one thing I think
another thing would be switching
exercises certain exercises will
inherently just put your muscles at
longer lengths and challenge them more
so in that position so for example if
you were to switch from doing a cable
pullover or a cable fly to doing a
dumball pullover or a dumbbell fly all
of a sudden your first of all no longer
performing a full range of motion for
the lats or the chest and the resistance
curve went from being relatively uniform
to all of a sudden you have the most
resistance being imposed in those more
lengthened positions so certain
exercises will simply be more lengthened
friendly or stretch friendly than others
the third thing I'd say is you can make
certain Tempo
modifications that may or may not help
with being more stretch friendly so for
example you could control the eent phase
a little bit more as you reach into
those longest muscle lengths during that
exercise or into that stress position
likewise you could briefly pause in that
stretch position and not pause in a
shorten position right the final thing
is you could be explosive or forceful
out of that length position so at the
very start of the concentric essentially
just try and produce as much tension as
possible when you're first starting the
concentric phase in that lengthen
position the other things are I would
say two kind of techniques and those
would be lengthen super sets or
essentially just when you finish your 4
in Motion Set do some lengthen partials
right so when you can't get another for
rep for example if you go into failure
just do some length and partials until
another defined end point right
alternatively for certain exercises
length and partials may not actually be
safe or even length and suets would't be
safe so if you're Barb about benching on
your own and you don't know how to you
know bail or what have you you may just
not want to do link partials cuz it's a
dangerous um and in that case you might
you you'll either figure it out or
you'll never be in a place where you
need to figure it out like it's that's a
that's a self-solving problem it is
really uh that's that's that's a bit
dark that's a bit dark I don't I don't
mean it if you don't feel safe Bing
alone don't don't put your life in your
own
hands to be clear it's not it's not the
position of the stronger by science
podcast that it is fine if you die
benching where we're we are against that
we are against that very good to clarify
I think it's important to do so um
regardless for certain exercises like
maybe the freee squat or the free bench
press or any exercises where you feel
might be a risk of crushing yourself
essentially um you may want to do
something called integrated partials
where instead of just doing partials or
doing some partials only after your full
reps maybe you kind of combine the two
you do a full rep you do a few partials
you do a full rep you do a few part
partials and repeat the process but you
make sure you end the set with a full
rep or you end the set when you can just
about get a full rep at the end that's a
fine approach as well and it will give
you probably most of the benefits of
just doing like partials but without
risking actually crushing yourself um
it's a fine approach and it can be a
nice gateway drug just like I know uh
you've discussed cannabis being um so
yeah that's broadly speaking how i'
would recommend it as far as baby steps
versus max M application I think like
Tempo stuff or so controlling the
Ecentric more in the lengthen position
pausing in lengthen position and being
explosive at the start of the concentric
phase and changes to excise selection
are probably like the baby steps thing
right we you're still doing a full range
of motion technically but you're just
kind of taking steps to emphasize the
length of position somehow meanwhile
what I would do personally if someone
came to me and was like look I want to
optimize hypertrophy I would probably
over the course of a month or two switch
them to like at least half of their
trading being link partials that's how I
see
it I think that does it for the
questions I had for you but uh the
audience also has some questions let's
kick it off with a question from
Reed so Reed asks uh Milo has been
talking about his research supporting
length and partials being Superior he's
also said that they'd be more applicable
to lifts where the shortened position is
mechanically harder than the lengthened
to allow for more l and overload however
I have a different takeaway from his
research that I was wondering his
opinion on that is I see it supporting
the notion that exercises where the
shorten position is harder are simply
inferior and we should choose exercises
where the lengthen position is harder by
default for instance instead of doing
standing lateral raises we should lay
down on our sides and perform unilateral
lineing lateral raises to make the
lengthened position the hardest and
apply the same mentality towards
basically all lifts so that that that
does relate to kind of the last thing
you were talking about but just to to
directly address his question what what
is your take on that 100% so readed I
actually do agree with you and I think
in general that is a fine way of
applying This research I think that
length and partials can simply serve as
a
nice way to level a playing field right
so certain pieces of equipment or
certain machines are going to be
probably better based on some of this
research for example if you have access
to a prime machine where you can buyas
the lengthen position right that's a
very Niche piece of equipment but it may
all together obviate the need for length
and partials because you can just load
that length position so much that it is
functionally length and partial however
length and partials are ultimately
what's been studied in the research and
so personally it's what I'm um partial
to pun intended in the sense that hey
it's what's been studied and if you want
to apply the results from the literature
to our own TR training then that is the
most Surefire way quote unquote to apply
it equally if you don't want to do
partials or if certain exercises may
also just be better right like if you're
comparing a Dumba lader raise even with
partials to an incline lying down ladder
raise the incline lying down ladder rise
is going to be a better option whether
you're doing length and partials or not
just because of how much of a difference
it makes to the muscle lengths involved
and to the res could involved so I think
honestly I would employ a combination of
these strategies if I was going to
optimize hypertrophy cuz just using L
and partials across the board may not be
the wisest approach cuz certain
exercises just aren't that good in line
of this stuff
but yeah I think switching exercises is
still a perfectly fine thing to do based
on This
research all right Kyle asks uh if
emphasizing the stretch position is
generally better for hyper hypertrophy
but the stretch shortening cycle lets
you move more weight which will produce
more muscle growth pause squats or
bouncing out of the hole so that's an
interesting question uh ultimately we
don't have any direct evidence on the
topic I think there's a few important
things to keep in mind here number one
is what allows you to use the most
weight on the bar is not necessarily
going to lead to the most growth right
example if you're doing a set of one rep
versus set of five reps you'll be able
to use more weight with set of one but
it is unlikely to lead to more muscle
growth so we don't just want to maximize
the load on the bar by a technique via
repetition range or have you um in this
case my hunch is that pausing would
probably be better you're
essentially making your quads glutes Etc
produce more tension at the bottom of
the squat if you have to stop the bar
from moving all together right um You
are producing more Force than if you're
resisting its sent right an asymmetric
is inherently going to require a greater
amount of force production than an
Ecentric phase here and so because
you're spending more time in that
lengthen position by pausing down there
and because you're producing more force
in that lengthen position by pausing
down there I think based on the research
it's probably going to be a better for
growth but it's worth keeping in mind
that one we're probably talking about a
pretty small difference and two we don't
have any direct research on the topic so
it may very well be that it's the other
way around
but based on the research we do have I
think it's probably worth pausing all
right
sanet uh has several questions and I'll
I I think I'll just ask you a couple of
these um the first is uh should uh
beginners to hypertrophy training use
lengthen partials do you do you think
people should just kind of like get some
experience with like quote unquote
normal training first or or just dive
straight into this if if you think it is
better for muscle growth grow that's a
great
question I'm of two minds of this on
this I think that it is probably worth
more so from a general education and
learning perspective to familiarize new
lifters with hey this is the for range
of motion for this exercise and maybe
they spend a few weeks doing it I think
that's a good idea just for their
long-term development like you know for
all we know maybe in a decade's time
more research comes out and it turns out
length and partials are more of a
situational tool or maybe they're
actually not as good for approach as you
thought I think for their development uh
in terms of knowledge and in terms of
long-term progress it is probably worth
teaching them what a for range of motion
would look
like equally though the studies we do
have comparing length and partials to
for Ranger motion have been
predominantly in relatively untrained
participants so I think if anything that
seems to be the population I would
be most open to using them in I know
some people have expressed concerns
about like oh beginners shouldn't worry
about anything when they're first
starting out and there is some truth to
that right like I think information
overload for people who are new to
lifting is a thing but I think in this
case why not consider what might give
them the best results especially if it's
relatively straightforward that's a nice
thing with range of motion as compared
to doing more volume for example is it
doesn't take you any additional time to
take the strategy that might lead to
better
results yeah I I do also wonder I also
wonder how how much of that comes from
the kind of more more old school concern
of like oh if if people are doing
partials but like short short muscle
length partials like it it can then be
difficult to like get them to train
through a full range of motion
subsequent to that like cuz that that is
that is a concern people have like if
you're not doing full range of motion
generally the default is you're doing
like partials but like in an ego lify
way so you know you you get your squad
up to 315 but you're only going through
45 degrees of knee flexion and then it
can be difficult to get someone to like
humble themselves and like take a ton of
weight off the bar to actually do a full
range of motion but like I do I do think
that something like that wouldn't be
relevant here cuz like if it turns out
down the road that long length partials
aren't Superior or who knows maybe after
someone's been training for a couple
years they're worse than full range of
motion like who knows what the future
will
hold it's not going to be difficult to
to teach someone to lock out a squat you
know it's like oh
uh it's it's a lot harder to say you
need to humble yourself and go down
deeper than you're already going down
all the way and guess what now you can
just stand up all the way and like take
a half second between reps you know
that's I don't think it would be
difficult to get someone on that tip
like I don't I don't think you're really
doing someone like a in instructional
disservice and in that
regard I do agree with you I think it
may be more so the case for certain
movements like a pull down in a row they
may just not if you never actually teach
them and this is assuming they're
completely Fitness agnostic when they
first come
in they may never like when they get
introduced to for range motion it may
take them a while to figure out oh okay
so you're supposed to stop the rep here
I don't know I don't think it makes a
huge difference either way to be honest
with you no I I agree um and yeah let's
let's close out on on uh this question
um is there benefit to slower Ecentric
if you're doing uh it like slowing down
your Ecentric when you're in a
lengthened position do you think that'll
lead to more muscle growth or do you
think it could reduce injury risk
actually don't even touch the injury
risk question we're not we're not
physical therapists here but do you
think that do you think that slowing
down the Ecentric at long muscle links
could could be another way to like eek
out
uh like a little bit of extra growth I
think it could be I think it falls under
the same category as just other ways of
emphasizing a lengthen position I don't
think like based on the evidence we have
around Ecentric duration you probably
don't need to take it overboard right
like a two to 3 second decentric is
plenty already like you don't need to do
a four to five six second decentric
necessarily in fact when you look at
repetition duration overall somewhere
between like a second and 8 seconds is
going to be roughly equivalent for
hypertrophy so I don't think there's any
value in inherently just lengthening the
Ecentric phase however if we're talking
about extending the Ecentric phase
specifically in length position so maybe
you lower the bar a little bit faster
when you're in the shorten position and
then you control it more as you reach n
length position it stands to reason that
it would help there hasn't been any
evidence on this directly but again it
stands to reason it's kind of the same
as a lot of these ways of applying it
and that's partly the trouble with
research is that we don't have direct
evidence
on all this stuff you need to make some
informed guesses when it comes to this
stuff or you could just say I'm only
going to do like the partials and that's
it it's up to you makes sense to me uh
you know what actually I I have one more
question for you just to just to kind of
close on so one of the things that that
strikes me a bit about lengthened
partials
and simultaneously the people who are
like really excited about them in a
positive way and people who are really
negative about them in a way of like ah
like these these young these young
coaches and trainers are trying to
reinvent the wheel and like take people
away from Basics like so both both on
like the positive and negative side of
things like how how much do you think a
lot of that comes down to people just
being being either really excited or
really prickly about new terms cuz like
what one of the things that strikes me
about a lot of this
is a lot of lengthened partials like the
way you would apply them is not all that
dissimilar to a lot of like the
bodybuilding tapes that I watched back
in the 90s and early alts where guys
were um like really emphasizing like
constant tension like I remember uh oh
there there was like a a Kai Green video
where he's talking about like oh yeah
these these like powerlifters are like
ego lifting when they do the bench press
they're like locking out and getting a
getting a rest between the Reps like you
really want to keep tension on the
muscle and like he's touching his chest
coming up about 2/3 of the way and going
back down like that those are lengthened
partials I guess but you know when when
you call it constant tension training or
keeping tension on the muscle that that
is um you know that that's something a
lot of people are either depending on
kind of effective veilance when exposed
to that either something they already
feel positively about or something that
they think is like old and boring and
they're already bored by but like it's
it's an idea that people are like
familiar with and I don't want to be
like too reductive and say that length
and partials are just exclusively con
constant tension training because it is
kind of like a framework to think about
things and apply things in a way that
people I think haven't historically
applied the the idea of like constant
tension training but to me it it does
seem like
a new idea but not in like a
revolutionary way just kind of like a a
tweak on something that does have a lot
of like just age and like DNA in
physical culture um and so yeah like I I
am I am curious like to to the extent
that it's caused like a lot of
discussion both positive and negative
how much do how much do you think it's
just like people being exposed to a new
term and just like immediately
responding positively or negatively that
there's a new word for
something I think a lot of it is that I
think a lot of it is a couple things one
that it is a new term and a new practice
and people just whenever they hear new
things it's like oh what's this now like
how do I need to change my training now
you know where the kids nowadays talking
about it's very reminiscent over the
sort of old man yells a cloud meme um in
some ways but the second thing is also I
think I have seen a sort of
counterculture movement where I think
evidence-based Fitness is kind of
becoming a trend or has become a
trend and I think there has been a
Counter Culture now where there is kind
culture where uh some people may not be
as receptive to new ideas anymore
and this might not even be an entirely
new idea as you mentioned in fact that
sometimes serve as ammunition I think
it's like we've known about this all
along Ry Coleman them or J Cutler them
or what have you the Bros right along so
why we listen to scientists and that
being used as an argument or as a
response kind of illustrates I think the
whole uh counterculture of ah who cares
about science just lift you know and
that's I understand where they're coming
from but equally I think that's a a
growing perspective within the industry
at this
point yeah I I don't know I I think I
think it's like an EB and flow and I
think it's a relatively fast EB and flow
cycle like I've I've been in this
industry for oh man now I'm I'm about to
sound like an old bastard like a back in
my day but no like I've been in this IND
industry since
20 11 I guess so like 12 years and i'
I've seen like kind of like sciency like
quote unquote evidence-based stuff kind
of have its moment in the Sun and be
ascendant and then there are to be like
a backlash by like the Bros probably
like four times already like it's we're
we're not talking about like decade long
Cycles like it's um it seems to be like
a it seems to be like a two to four year
cycle where you know one thing's popular
than than the other things popular this
time around honestly I think what it was
was the pandemic I think like people
were cooped up inside for like a year
and a half and like couldn't lift that
much but like so their outlet for their
hobby was just reading about lifting and
that's going to get you into the science
stuff and so I think that like I think
that like the the
pandemic was really like the house on
days not necessarily like monetarily
because like Fitness industry pandemic
was pretty rough but in terms of like uh
like ideas gaining purchase with within
people who consume content I think I
think the pandemic was like pretty
pretty [__] tight for for nerds um
and now I think people are kind of out
and about and going about life and so
yeah there's there is just like more of
a backlash it's just like I spent two
years just like reading stuff on my
computer screen and so now like I don't
want to have to think about this stuff
and I don't want to have to think about
science like I just want to go smash
some [__] weights and um so yeah I
don't know I think I think give it
another year things will probably swing
back like it's it it it es and flows
like it it always does yeah it's just
been interesting obviously somewhat
being at the center of uh this length
and partial stuff it's been interesting
to see the reaction of uh I guess a
well-intentioned public but it's it's
interesting how heterogenous
heterogeneous the response has been as
well
and like that's um mhm and also how the
interpretations have varied
fundamentally like some people will take
this and run to the store with it and
just be like Yep this is going to
revolutionize your gains uh just my back
exploded and stuff whereas some people
like yeah this we've known this for 40
Years bro uh in the 70s ' 80s actually
at this point the BS were doing this
already yeah yeah it is uh I I've
noticed this same thing like
any any like kind of new idea is
simultaneously like so old it's boring
cuz people were like Bill Bill Pearl did
this in the 50s and also like such a
radical departure from like normal ways
of training that it's like dangerous and
scary it's like ah choose a lane choose
a lane agreed yeah it's fun it's fun I I
do
Wonder uh and for for people listening I
think we're I think we're probably done
with like sciency content I suspect we
might just like shoot the [__] for a
little while and then at some point in
the episode but like I do I do Wonder
like a lot of the discourse around this
stuff I wonder how much like change in
social media platforms has like affected
that because maybe like two cycles of
this ago everyone was still on Facebook
and so if someone said something you
didn't like um it was also like way more
of a text based platform back then like
now there's been a big pivot to video
and like blah blah blah and all that
[__] but like for the most part it
used to just be like someone would post
an article and people would argue about
it in the comment section for like
several days um and you know there there
were problems with that but it did I
think to some extent
encourage direct engagement with
whatever was like D direct
prolonged somewhat realtime engagement
with people you disagreed with
um and these days like I don't know with
Instagram and Tik Tok now is kind of
like where a lot of people have moved to
it seems like there's less discussion
about things and more just like response
videos and then response videos to the
response videos and a lot of times like
folks just kind of talking past each
other and
when it was just like a long Facebook
comment thread everyone it was very easy
for an onlooker to just pull up the
comment thread and if someone was like
bing someone else it would be obvious
but now like you you no one wants to go
back and forth between two profiles to
you know look at an extended
exchange um in a medium where like it's
it's more difficult to like cite your
sources and link stuff and a lot of
times it's taking place in stories like
it's ephemeral so if you missed a
screenshot you missed like a third of
whatever com like controversy was going
back and forth like I don't know I
do I do think I I want to say that
that's made things worse but I am also
sensitive to the idea that I might just
be getting old and out of touch
cuz I don't know I don't think that many
people look back fondly on Facebook of
2014 but I kind of
do yeah I mean hey to summarize that
they don't make beef like they used to
you know back in the day you could just
scroll the Facebook uh post and see
everything I do agree with you and I
think with it being a lot more visual
nowadays and more video based it can be
difficult to convey the same information
that is usually just cited from articles
um because I think when you can can just
skim read something you can read a
comment that sites papers and still have
it be fairly intelligible but if you're
watching a video of someone sting papers
Etc that's a bit of a harder cell for a
lot of people um you need to make it
very engaging and so that's actually
something I've been trying to do on
YouTube but it's I do think that text
lends itself probably better to actual
uh actual debate actual science
communication yeah also now I'm really
going to sound like an old bastard
everyone's on their phones these days
but like I I do actually think that's a
bad thing cuz again if someone wants to
site a source and you want to pull it up
I'll tell you what I don't want to scam
a PDF on my phone like but if I'm on my
laptop it's nice used to be you know
traffic was like 80% from laptops and
desktops and now it's like 70% from
mobile devices uh and yeah I don't know
I I think I think in a scientific
discussion it's so much harder to engage
if both people are primarily engaging
through their phones cuz like phones are
so much worse for for reading stuff on I
agree I do think uh at this point we're
one moment away from story to discuss
text NE
syndrome um and whether or not is
scientifically correct yeah you know I
think things were actually a lot better
when people needed to like chisel their
thoughts into like in in uniform on
tablets because like when when you're
just typing on a keyboard like you can
you can delete like it's very ephemeral
um you can make edits but like if you're
chiseling something into stone you
really need to think about it beforehand
so I think that that lended itself to
like much more like deeper well well
reasoned debates yeah no I yeah I I was
just feeling reminiscent uh nostalgic
about the fitness community of old I
guess
but whatever things
change take take the good with the bad
hey man it is what it is um one day
we'll get back to bodybuilding.com forms
oh my God I would [__] love that uh
yeah yeah I'm not I'm not you you're
trying you're trying to trick me
into continuing to like reveal more and
more of my Boomer Tendencies and like I
was willing to go back to Facebook but
yeah dude [__] forums God the for The
Forum Arrow was the best um but yeah no
no uh I think I think we need to wrap
this episode up we're I was going to say
we're getting further off the rails I'm
getting further off the rails I can I
can take that one on the chin um so yeah
just to just to wrap up do you have any
just final final thoughts or takeaways
to leave the audience with also one
final question aren't you glad we didn't
also do high volume training in this
episode as well man if we did that it
genuinely would have been like 7 hours
or something it would have been absurd
um final thoughts so I don't know range
of motion wise if you're competing in
strength sports or any other sports
probably be specific for the most part
train the range of motion that you want
to train in for hypertrophy consider
emphasizing length of position somehow
might be some partials might be certain
excises that do it better might be some
Tempo stuff or just some partials at the
end of the set overall
you know I hope this was informative I
hope this was a good
podcast I think it was uh or at least
your your contributions to it were good
I don't I don't think I was at the top
of my game today but you know that's how
it goes sometimes uh and I I appreciate
you for for sticking it out with me um
Milo if if the folks want to to follow
you and keep up to date with you and the
research you're doing and discussing
where where can the people out there
find you for sure so I think the place
I'm most active nowadays and really
pushing for is YouTube so you can find
me on YouTube at Wolf coaching equally
if you want to find me on Instagram you
can find me at Wolf coach that's my last
name and coach and finally for my
research stuff I would search Milo wolf
so my full name and research gate and
you can find all my research output on
there including the rang of motion stuff
but also some other papers on for
example RP or reps and Reserve accuracy
D Lo studies all that sort of stuff
sounds great well Milo thanks thanks
again for coming on uh and for everyone
who who listened and stuck it out this
far um thank you uh we love you we
appreciate you and uh I'll I'll talk to
you again in a couple weeks
[Music]
goodbye